start again if everybody can mute
themselves
i can do it but i'd prefer if you do it
yourself
i need to begin with this as chair of
the house public works
and highways committee i find that due
to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covet 19 pandemic
in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-0
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee orientation meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the pub excuse me and the public has
access
to listen and if necessary participate
in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar
in the general court website the notice
for this meeting
complies with house rules and rsa 91
a anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should call 271
six zero zero or email
hcs at leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
this meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
in the meeting with us
and assisting that is brad
greenland our committee researcher brad
is on
and he's going to be an important part
of our committee going forward
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let us
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
this is in accordance with house rules
that the clerk has to keep a record of
who is there
when each member states their present
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
i would ask our clerk representative
thank you mr chair i think everybody can
um we'll start the chairman john graham
is here
i'm alone except for my dog which i may
vice chairman mark mcconkey uh thank you
mr clerk i am president
i am here by myself presently dogs and
cats will pass through
thank you the clerk david mills is here
i have also alone my wife's at another
floor of the house
with our cats representative sumero
yes i'm here and my why i'm alone
thank you representative philadelphia
representative philadelphia
can you hear me now i can hear you now
yes sir
okay that's that little microphone i
guess
anyway i'm here my wife is in the house
somewhere
she'll be wandering in and out thank you
uh also as soon as this is our first
time calling the roll
please don't hesitate to correct me if i
get your name wrong i've got to do this
for the rest of the for the rest of the
next two years so
representative clifford newton
okay representative
i can see the clipper newton is here but
yeah oh there we go
yeah it took a while to unmute yes i am
here my wife is
currently on the treadmill she'll be
wandering in and out but she knows i'm
in a meeting so
she won't be bothering us thank you
representative melissa blasic here
and i'm alone my family's upstairs
greg representative mike can you stay
out here for like two minutes
i just have to say i'm here and then i'm
representative mike boards
okay let's move on representative
kaczynski
yes i'm here and my wife is in another
part of the house on a zoo meeting
herself thank you
representative thompson i am here
i am alone in the room oh however my
wife is in the house
thank you sir representative
thank you representative cloudier
uh good morning i'm representative john
clutier i'm alone in my
bedroom my brother who lives with me is
in another part of the house
representative edgar president
i'm alone in the room my wife's in the
house so is cb
representative ebel um good morning i'm
home
alone in new london
representative jack i'm here i'm alone
representative abbott here
representative faulkner here in swansea
my wife is in the other room
representative newman
yes i'm here i'm alone in the house
right now my husband
might come into the house at some point
um but i'm here thank you
representative pedersen
michael peterson here and alone
thank you representative query
i represented query here alone other
than my dog
representative bunker present
in exeter i'm alone currently but my
wife might pass through from time to
all right and once again i'm going to go
through the three that did not respond
in case there are now
thank you mr chair we have 20 of our 23
members
present
thank you mr clerk um we are going to
spend a couple of hours today as i told
you in the email
to go over both some of the ground rules
and what the committee does
as well as get to know each other
hopefully a little bit it's not the same
as doing it
in person but it's a start and then we
will hear
from the legislative budget office on
the capital budget process
which is our biggest um
item in front of us this coming next
three or four months
and also a quick brief from the
treasurer
on the status of our bonds and
uh borrowing capability within the state
but to start i'd like everybody in the
same order that we were called
because that normally i'd go around the
table that's a little harder without a
table
to introduce themselves please take
about three minutes or so
just to let everybody know who you are
and we can start putting
faces to um names
and a lot uh there's seven or eight new
members of the committee
so it'll be good to do this i will start
i'm uh obviously the chair appointed by
the speaker
and i live in bedford i grew up in
massachusetts
um went to boston university and then
spent
about 21 years in the army um
traveling around the world that go to
all kinds of fun places
and once i returned to the states
um i knew i wasn't going to live in the
commonwealth
so i found a nice place here in bedford
and got
uh asked by one of my neighbors to run
for
the state house and i ran in 2000
and other than one term i've been here
ever since
and this is my 10th term and 10th term
on the public works committee
i've also been the deputy majority
leader
republican whip i served on the ethics
committees
for two years so i kind of know what
we're doing here
and i appreciate all of those who came
back
on the committee to help um
leaven the experience that we have
because it's always a challenge
the first bill with the capital budget
and now vice chair uh thank you mr
chairman
mark mcconkey i live in freedom
i spent my youth in massachusetts
i went to college springfield college
i've been in new hampshire for
30 plus years i have served
seven terms beginning my eighth term uh
like john i've spent all of my time here
on public works
i've been a chairman i've been a vice
chairman
[Music]
and i am the thing that pleases me most
about being part
of this committee is that we have not
looked at the individuals as party
we work cohesively we do everything we
can to pass everything out with the
majority
and many times unanimously and
so i look forward to being with you i
know
more democrats on this committee than
than republicans and we have
we have a great wealth of knowledge
between us
uh i'm here to help anyone at any time
it's the first time that i've ever
served that we're sitting with
three chairmen and three vice chairmen
of this committee
and an awful lot of knowledge going
forward so
a little background about myself i
served as a zoning chairman in ospy for
15 years i've been a member of the lakes
region planning commission on the
executive board
uh 15 years i like to do things for a
long period of time
and i'm here and and available in
whatever i can do
to either assist my chairman or any of
you please call on me
representatives uh thank you mr chairman
before i go on
to my little spiel i just wanted to know
whether you've got the uh
you've got the list in front of you to
call people in the order you would like
or you want me to do that
oh i'll let you do that david oh well
okay only because i figured
not everybody knows what order they
exactly they were called in and i'm sure
they won't remember it so
anyway i'm david mills i'm uh i'm on my
fifth term here i
uh also like like our previous two
speakers all on the
public works i've been the vice chair
and this will be my second time being
the clerk
i'm a actual chicago boy born and raised
but i had the pleasure of working for
continental airlines as their general
manager for
20 years and this was one of the places
in boston i was assigned to manage
and i i couldn't get new hampshire out
of my blood so i came back and retired
here
i'm a veteran of the air force i served
in vietnam
i guess i mentioned i worked for
continental airlines and retired
once i came to derry i got uh active in
politics i was the
east area fire commissioner i've been a
town counselor
i've been on the zoning board i've been
um
i'm currently on the housing authority
here in derry
and as echoed before by our previous two
i i can't think of a better committee
i'd rather be on than
public works we're grounded in getting
things done
we we take care of the state's
infrastructure and a capital budget
and very rarely very very rarely does
partisan politics ever come into
anything that we do here so i'm looking
forward to another
great two years thank you and up after
me
is representative paul cimarro yeah hi
everybody i'm paul and
i grew up in detroit michigan
at 17 years old i moved to new hampshire
and i've been in construction
all my life my career i did
manufacturing of construction equipment
and then it was this is my third term
here
in the state house and i've been on
public works now this will be my
third third term in public works but i
do
want to testify that the public works
committee has been
very interesting and i've enjoyed
being involved with everybody in on the
committee
and it's been very nice to work there so
thank you representative next up is uh
representative jim phidolfi
i started out in the air force i was
in force intelligence i was a radio
when i got out shortly thereafter
i got married a wonderful woman
after a couple years we moved to new
hampshire we've been in the hand canal
53 years i own the construction company
designed to build over 111
commercial industrial buildings
including one of the
uh biggest classman building east in the
mississippi
down in massachusetts uh
during the bush one of the bush
administrations
they went bankrupt i then started
valuemark retail store in
chichester new hampshire sold it about
15 years ago
moved to hillsborough new hampshire
uh it's a wonderful place
this is a great committee that president
spoke before said that politics doesn't
you'll appreciate that i know i do
i'm getting a little tired of politics
anyway i'm gonna have to leave you early
my wife caught coven i helped her out
stayed with her i caught coping
i have to go lie down i'll
thank thank you for coming jim we
appreciate you
uh at least introducing yourselves
and having been on the committee you
know a lot of what the
legislative budget assistant is going to
say as well as
how the treasurer works so thank you for
all right mr chair next up is uh
represent representative newton are you
there still
yep i am like
i'm off on having a little trouble with
okay i can't hear you though so i'll
just keep going uh
again uh this is my fourth term as a
state rep
i'm a first time elected was 2002
elected again in 2004 and elected again
in 11 and 12. i've been on the education
committee
the labor committee and at 11 12 i
became chair of the fish and game
uh glad to be here happy to be on this
committee i like the
non-divisiveness by the sounds of things
thank you sir representative melissa
blasic
hi um well i'm from new hampshire
born and raised um i
am a musician i own a private music
school here in merrimack
we're actually in my studio um and
the i'm wildly green i've this is my
first time
ever holding office so i'm excited to be
here
thank you next up is representative
hi um i'm 65 years old married
and have a college age daughter
i i'm a live poultry dealer
it's a family business my grandfather
started in 1934
we grew it through the years started in
connecticut where i lived most of my
life
we've grown it to be the largest
supplier of hens to new york city
uh i was born and raised in connecticut
as i said and moved to 19 up here in
mainly for business concerns and
i'm here to stay as far as politics
i wasn't elected to the local office but
got involved we
enacted a tax cap in rochester in 2008
and uh i worked with the
less restrictive zoning policy 2011-14
and i was elected a state rep in uh
2014 in 2016
and served on the edna committee and
i missed the last session but
winning in 2020 i was happy to try a new
committee out and i'm looking forward to
learning more of the workings of this
david representative bortis
thank you mr chair uh and a good thing
he's he's
up next then give us a little recap of
himself
hi how you doing i'm mike boards i am
originally
from long island new york um
i worked in radio and the museum for 20
something years
moved up to new hampshire about five six
years ago
love it up here and uh i look forward to
thank you sir next up is representative
dennis thompson
uh good morning folks uh i'm dennis
thompson i live up in stewartstown new
hampshire i represent coast district one
um along with another gentleman donald
dusty
um my wife and i have uh
both been in new hampshire well i've
been here my entire life my wife has
been here most of her life
we own a uh special projects
construction company
the majority of the work we do is for
state agencies
and local towns solving
what many would consider unsolvable
problems
we do a lot of our work for new
hampshire cultural resources
in the restoration of historic sites
around the state of new hampshire
we constructed the monument for the old
man of the mountain
been franconia notch we've redone the
sea walls on
fort stark on newcastle island
and currently i'm sitting here on the
shore of the beautiful atlantic ocean
restoring a 750-foot sea wall
this is my first term in office i've
never gotten into politics before
but the older i get the more i see
things i didn't like in politics and i
thought it was time to try and
do something to affect where
things go particularly in my area in the
north country
pretty much think that's all there is to
know about me i'm not a
i'm not a lawyer i've never been a bank
president i've been in the construction
industry for 48 years
and i went to high school in concord at
concord high
thank you thank you sir uh
representative susan
i'm coming guys hold on one second
oh fantastic all right well you got my
name
spelt right and you said it properly
it's susan van de castille castillo
this is my first term running in one for
politics
it's also my first time being a
republican i was
independent for ever since i started
voting
so my girls asked me to
run for a state representative for the
town of salem which i did in
surprisingly one which i'm excited and
i'm excited to be on this
board because i was born and raised in
salem
and raised by a third generation
mechanic so i was one of the first
few female registered mechanics for the
state of new hampshire and the state
inspector
in 1991. i've since then stopped turning
wrenches
and i work at a dealership and customer
service
and i've got some great ideas for our
highway and transportation hopefully i
can fit in
thank you very much representative john
cloutier
uh thank you uh mr clerk uh again i'm
representative john clutier from
claremont
i'm now believe it or not in my 15th
term and my 14th term on this committee
and i served as i said uh
and i bet served on every position on
this committee
uh you know including clerk vice chair
ranking member and
last term i had the honor of serving as
chair of the public works and highways
committee
and the one term i was not on this
committee i came to appreciate
this committee better i mean the
committees i served on were okay but
they were not like public works and
highways where we can really get some
things done for the rest of our state
and although we have our disagreements i
think we don't
really descend into partisanship too
much
and so i've really enjoyed my time on
this committee i've made a lot of good
friends not only present
members of the committee but people who
are no longer member reps or members of
this
committee and i again look forward to
serving on this committee
um and i am my background is right now
i'm a security office private security
officer substitute teacher
i've done other things in my life like
drive buses
been a newspaper reporter been a
community organizer but that's what i'm
right now is private security and
substitute teaching
and i'm a native of claremont and i've
lived
in claremont most of my life in new
hampshire
all of my life and i really look forward
to working with this committee to do our
part
in improving the state and thank you
very much mr clerk uh and mr chair
thank you sir next up is mr michael
edgar
uh thanks dave yeah i'm mike edger i
represent hampton
uh i was very fortunate to be assigned
to this committee i want to say that
right up front
i lobbied for it and uh i got it and i
was really glad to get reassigned to it
but uh i actually grew up in a little
fishing village in connecticut uh
stonington connecticut
the only one to be attacked twice by the
british and repulsed them twice
and uh and it was basically uh but that
was in uh
back in 1776 and 1814
um after that i uh went to uconn
then after uconn i i hit the road went
out to michigan and worked and i've been
working construction projects most of my
life mostly power plants
but uh then once i was assigned up this
way uh
after several years and when we had four
kids before we had five
my wife said we weren't moving so uh and
that was good for me because we really
liked the place
it's a good place to be um and that was
back like i said back in
well in 76 is when we moved here
so um i was uh
basically like i said worked uh
construction most of my life i was also
in the service
uh i was kind of in the army in the 60s
for a few years that's a long story but
then i was in the navy for a little over
um they finally kicked me out when i
turned 62 and 09
and i was very fortunate to uh work with
again construction side
with the seabees the whole time
and uh i was very fortunate to be
assigned to go to several
places uh uh as a reservist i was uh
mobilized or uh called up several times
it was uh it was a great experience and
uh
get to be an awful lot of different
people that way so
uh as i said i i'm just really glad to
be on this committee it's a great
committee to be on
and just look forward to the next next
couple of years on it
thank you mike next up is representative
karen ebel
good morning everyone um i'm
karen ebel i live in new london
presently
i'm really pleased to be back on this
committee again
where i have many friends i'm in my
fifth
term on the committee
i was born and raised in ossipee over in
representative mcconkey's neck of the
woods
ended up going to college over in
vermont where i
majored in biology and biochemistry of
all things
and after doing that for a couple of
years i ended up going to law school
and at georgetown in washington dc
met my husband there um worked as a
corporate attorney in d.c
for about 10 years and then came to we
came to our senses
uh and left the big city he was from
ohio
i persuaded him new hampshire was a
better place to go
so we came up here we've been in in new
london
for about 32 years i served on the
new london planning board for almost 20
years like
representative mcconkey once i start
something it seems to go for a while
but i chaired it for about a decade
done various volunteer positions that
sort of thing and then
decided to run for office ended up on
public works and highways
and i'm really glad i did it's been a
great experience you really get to
do meaningful things for your district
and for your state
as i said you meet a lot of great people
um
in my last term i served as deputy
speaker
under speaker shertliff and
once covid struck i was very deeply
involved in developing the remote
capabilities
for um for the committee so if you don't
like zoom webinar you can
kind of blame me anyway and now
i'm serving as the democratic leader
pro tem and i'm very pleased to be here
and i look forward to working with you
all
thank you karen uh next up is uh martin
jack representative martin jack
yeah hi i'm uh marty jack i'm also uh
in uh starting my fifth term i've been
on the committee the whole time
and last term i was honored to be the
clerk
uh i'm also a chicago boy i came out
here to college
and i moved up to new hampshire in 1978
i had a wonderful career uh doing
engineering for one of the
larger computer manufacturers
and so i think that's helpful uh having
an engineering background
the chairman mentioned that you get to
he went he
got to go a lot of interesting places
the new people will find that on this
committee
you will get to go a lot of interesting
places because we build things and then
sometimes we get to take a tour of them
and
you'll go places that uh people don't
get to go normally
and certainly people on other committees
don't get to go
so
i guess in the interest of time i'll
thank you and i just want to point out
as the vice chair said
we work collegially uh within this
committee
and since uh representative jack has
been
the committee clerk previously if uh
representative mills has not had a
hearing
i'm gonna ask representative jack to
fill in
um i'd be delighted you expected that
didn't you
good thank you okay
um all right next up
is uh representative um michael abbott
my name's michael abbott and i'm
starting my fourth term
uh my third term on public works and
highways
um i along with three other members of
the house
represent cheshire district one which is
towns of
chesterfield and stale walpole and
westmoreland
um i was born in pittsfield
massachusetts
both of my parents were natives
of north adams massachusetts and
their first generation american citizens
my father fought in the second world war
and he was in the national guard when it
was federalized
and he fought in north africa and italy
and he went in as a corporal and came
out as a captain
because i guess the germans were trained
he had a choice between an enlisted
man and an officer he shot the officer
and
after the war um he
married my mother who had been a
high school language teacher for 11
years and they had my older brother than
myself
my father remained in the national guard
but then opted to go back
into the service and consequently
we went all over the country
and also when he was assigned to
berlin germany for three years we went
there
um his last station was he was the army
advisor he was a dead by then a
lieutenant colonel
he was the army adviser to western mass
national guard
worked out of the howard street armory
in springfield mass and we lived in long
meadow mass where i went
the last three years of high school and
i went to brown university
and um graduated from there in 1970
with a degree in political science
i had out three options at that point
and accepted at suffolk law school
had been offered a job as a systems
analyst for travelers insurance
and offered a job teaching social
studies at hinsdale high school
i had had it with formal education at
that point so i opted not to go to law
school
and being a 60s person i really wasn't
ready to join corporate america
so i went to hansdale high school for 6
a year and i taught um
three two classes of ninth grade civics
and three classes of 11th grade us
history
and i did that for 15 years and i also
because
i played football at both high school
and college
and wrestled at both levels and
became involved in coaching hinsdale did
not have a football team nor did they
have one now
and i started with junior high soccer
worked my way up
i also became involved with the nhia the
new hampshire interscholastic athletic
association
and um and proceeded at this point i
guess i was ready for formal education
to get
my master's degree in educational
administration at keene state college
and i became in 1985
the principal of hansdale high school
and remained there for 15 years and
again with my involvement with the nhiaa
i was a member and then chairman of the
nhiaa soccer committee
from 1980 to 2000
and i was also on the executive
committee of the nhiaa and served as the
president
for one year and then i got done there
and i uh went to work for
in the buying department cns wholesale
grocers
the corporate headquarters in keene
and then decided um when i reached
66 to uh
since i had taught civics that maybe it
was time for me to try and
put it into practice i've lived in
hinsdale for 50 years
my wife and i have been married for 46.
and one uh child daughter
and um 11 year old granddaughter and a
eight-year-old grandson and that's the
story of my life
thank you representative next up is
representative barry
faulkner great hi
barry faulkner i'm throwing my third
term again all in public works and
highways
um i grew up in keene
uh but we moved back to new hampshire 15
years ago
i ended up in swansea so i was in
swansea and richmond
um i'm a
land use lawyer in keene
but prior to that i had a 30-year career
in transportation planning
i'm involved in developing transit
highway
airport access projects across the
country
um so that's really kind of the
source of my interest and and what our
we've got region american government and
and city planning from harvard and of
course my
large agreement was from suffolk um
we're living on a farm here in swansea
our kids are
grown grandchildren living in the boston
area so
that's that's my story in a nutshell
thank you sir next up i was going to
mention
one one other thing if i can uh there's
also a reason why this is important to
me
the fifth generation of faulkners from
keem to serve in this house
and uh i really kind of honor the
honor to to play that role and uh
my four predecessors uncle grandfather
great grandfather great great
grandfather all republicans so
uh i i
i come from a from a a long line of uh
perhaps
hope that that makes it easier to cross
the aisle sometimes and work with you
guys so that's
that's my story thank you um
next up is representative sue newman
yes good morning everyone i'm coming
near the end
this is really impressive listening to
everybody's stories
um i feel like i got nothing but this is
what i have
my husband ray newman is also a state
rep he's on criminal justice
he's in his second term i'm on my third
term at the state house
been on public works and highways for
the duration
we've lived in nashua new hampshire for
40 years
i'm originally from western upstate new
york rochester
and after leaving rochester
it was the vietnam era my husband was in
the service
we were assigned to a post in germany
so i lived in schweibershall germany for
a while then we went to
florida then after that was georgia
virginia
and then we got to new hampshire and
we've been here for the last 40 years
we have three grown children six
grandchildren
and during my time in nashua
i've been a realtor for 25 years
uh and i was on the board of education
for eight years in nashua
interesting part of traveling around the
state
the southern part of the state when
people were moving in moving out
whatever
were the road conditions that i noticed
all along the way so public service i
i thought was fascinating to really see
how the infrastructure is
um it's financed it's organized and
and how it's so vital to the state of
new hampshire
thank you next up is representative
hi uh michael peterson state
representative
second term from nashua this is also my
second term
on the public works and highways
i won't go into my entire life story but
i'll tell you i have a
an engineering degree from wentworth
institute in boston
newton massachusetts girl we have three
daughters
and we've been living in
new hampshire for 27 years
and um i am now widowed
and i have three adult daughters and um
i also aside from being a state
representative i serve on the nashua
city planning board and that's
interesting and relevant
just like this particular committee is
also relevant
to the people of new hampshire so uh
in the last term uh to borrow
um an expression we worked collegially
and uh that was really good to know
and i can look forward to doing good
work in this committee again
this term thank you
thank you sir uh next up is um
representative joshua query
hi everyone uh i'm josh query uh i live
in
ward 9 of manchester um i grew up in
rural indiana
uh and i moved to manchester at 18.
so 10 years ago this coming july um i
graduated from new hampshire institute
of art
uh in 2016 with a degree in ceramics and
minor and print making um i grew up
surrounded by
uh construction with my father's steel
manufacturing company
so i kind of got a real in depth of
building maintenance and you know
infrastructure from a young age
since graduating college i've worked as
an educator a studio manager
an art restorer i've worked in
construction
and most recently or currently i should
say
a ups package handler so working from
12 a.m to uh 8 a.m so if you got a
christmas package from ups
uh i probably loaded it on there um
and uh this coming fall i am going to be
returning to school part-time getting a
master's in architectural design
thank you sir um finally mr chairman
our last person to speak is
representative lisa bunker
hello good morning everyone i'm lisa
bunker i'm
starting my second term as a new
hampshire state rep representing the
town of exeter
last term i served on the ways and means
committee
i gather i'm the only new democrat on
public works
this this term i'm here because although
i found ways and means interesting in
many ways i wanted to work on a
committee that actually had
that did work that actually impacted the
lives of granite staters in a direct way
and also because i was looking for a
place that was non-partisan and
collegial and i asked around and heard
that this was the place to be
i'm a relative newcomer to new hampshire
i moved to exeter just under five years
ago
when i met the person to whom i am now
married i lived before in maine i've
also
had homes in washington state new mexico
california pensacola florida
i worked 30 years in public broadcasting
in many of those places i just mentioned
i am now currently self-employed as a
writer
i've had two novels for young readers
published in the last three years
and i'm working on a number of new
projects
i should note that although i am a
relative newcomer to new hampshire
my eight times great grandfather john
bunker
um a pre-revolutionary war farmer is
buried outside of durham
so um i was away for a while but now i'm
back
thank you and mr chair uh it's uh this
concludes our little
auto biographical briefing and it's all
ah thank you mr clerk um
as you see we have a pretty diverse
group with a lot of different
backgrounds
but that's helpful as we go through
the various bills that we will be
getting
we'll talk about the workload a little
everybody took less time than i thought
i thought we'd spend at least an hour on
this if
23 members at three minutes each but
that's okay
we're going to go forward um
the only thing i'm going to ask is
if you leave the meeting for some reason
just make that known if you have to
leave for
a break of some kind
darken your screen so that we know that
that's the reason and uh mr vice
chairman if mine goes dark you're in
charge
um let's go over some of the uh
the ground rules now that we've gotten
to know each other
and you're really getting a little bit
short changed by doing it via zoom
because a lot of the relationships are
built as we have a cup of coffee
during breaks in the committee and the
rest and you just talk with people
we will start doing that uh sometime in
the near future
and we'll talk about that in a little
bit as well
um the idea
um is that all of our meetings
will be noticed in the house calendar
whether it's in person or uh
remotely via zoom and they will appear
and it's my goal to start on time
i know a couple times when i filled in
his chair over the years people would
water back
after lunch when the calendar said we
started at one they'd show up at
110 and i'd already started the meeting
so if it's in the calendar to start at a
certain time
i i do want to start on time um
if at all possible
um second i think did everybody
see the email from the house clerk about
an email address
where he asks that you have a single
email
for all of this so that notices that
come out
about committee meetings because you
will get notified whether it's in person
or zoom or if you have a bill being
heard
you'll also be notified electronically
i know in the past some members have
said oh committee should use
uh billy bob at uh gmail.com and not
what was
listed on the house um website
the clerk the speaker and i all ask that
you pick one
and use it because when i send an email
out all i'm going to do is go to the
the public works page on the house
site and just hit the button that says
email
all um committee members it's just so
much easier
um so hopefully that will be the way
that it is
um but let me know and let the court a
house clerk
know more importantly if the one that is
on your web page
is not the one that you want use for all
of this type of thing
if you have a question you can do it
either way just
raise your hand or there's a little
raise your hand button at the bottom
are you on the phone are you talking
never mind
yeah he's on the phone okay
um public meetings whether it's via zoom
or in person are just that they're open
to the public
and we are representatives not only of
our own town
but also the entire state so please
dress accordingly i know that there
is not a formal dress code for the house
but it is expected both on the house
floor and
in committee that you dress
appropriately
and for many many years and
for me at least that means coat and tie
for the gentleman and i'm not going to
try to tell the ladies what is
appropriate
we've been down that one before uh
but um please um do that
and decorum is important um we're not
there um as our for our personal
uh agendas on the committee
we may have bills in on various other
committees that express what you want
but please no talking across
other people while testimony is going on
and we'll get into how that works in
just a few minutes but
you are representative of the house
and anything you say or do will probably
be recorded by somebody
and if it's not great we will all hear
so when we get into the
legislative uh office building there is
a committee room
that has drawers the returning members
whichever committee will know what i'm
talking about where you can store things
those will not be open until we resume
normal operations
within the state within the state house
complex so
you're going to have to drag your stuff
back and forth every day that we have
meetings in concord just be aware of
that
it looks like it's going to be probably
after crossover
hopefully everybody remembers what
crossover is
before we really get everything um under
control within the entire complex
and that's just a function of being
vaccinated
and the rest um but once we get into
them
you're free to leave whatever you want
in there please don't leave too much
food
because there is the potential for mice
and ants and
other things which has happened in other
committees and not
ours um and please don't lock them and
take the
the key with you um sometimes you'll
lock
it and then other members um drawers
will even not close all the way or won't
open
um if you're going to don't like the key
sticking out put it in the drawer
and and do that um seating assignments
we'll do that when our first meeting
um returning members you can go to
the seat that you won um
or where you were and the others we can
fill in
i know that in some of the literature it
says
uh the chairman assigns it that's never
been the way within
public works um so we'll we'll try to
work on that
um the first time and if you don't like
where your name
tag's been placed uh by our commit uh
assistant um feel free to move it and
talk with the other people around you
the only ones that can't change are
myself
the vice chair and the um
clerk we have to be at the the head i've
always sat at the end of one of
the arms of the u um for
nine terms i kind of liked it because i
could
exit quickly if i had to but now i'm
stuck at the
head of the table and then we'll also go
over
the fire exits fire alarms and those
types of things
the first are there any questions about
just kind of ground rules and decorum
and okay moving on
the committee um i
have been told by the speaker to do this
rule 30 is the charge to the committee
it shall be the duty of the committee on
public works and highways
to consider all matters pertaining to
the development
and repair of public highways the
highway fund
the turnpike fund buildings and capital
construction
the capital budget matters pertaining to
state bonding authority
capital expenditures related to the
improvement and preservation of the
coastline
the care of state memorials and
monuments and such
other matters as may be referred to
that's kind of in
a nutshell it kind of explains
bills here in a few minutes hopefully
everybody has looked at the house rules
either in preparation for our last
session
and what changes were being proposed or
not proposed
or not passed but
there are important pieces in there to
include the responsibilities of members
on committees as you looked at the
makeup
and listened to the roll call
we have a larger committee than usual
we have 23 members which makes it one of
the largest um committees in the house
we're larger than the finance committee
at the moment and the partisan breakout
is 12 republicans 11 democrats
um so i don't know what that means
when we come down to voting but i do
know that it means that
the the speaker when i talked to him
about it said that we work collegially
so we could work out our differences
and get things passed as um
the the clerk and the vice chair have
said in the in
their opening remarks we tried to get
things out
and representative clutier also talked
about this
we try to get things out on a consensus
basis
we don't always all agree and there have
been you know
um times where we've we've had partisan
fights
um the one that comes to mind to me is
uh passenger rail
and whether or not to to go forward with
that
um if that is a partisan issue
but by and large most of ours come out
when we had 20 or 19 to one or 18 to
zero
depending on who was there and it just
makes it easier to work
on the floor of the house to to get
things done
if we can reach consensus through
amendments
any questions on the charge to the
committee
okay let's talk about
typical bills and if any of the
returning members want to chime in while
capital budget is the big one that we'll
be dealing with
um the first part of this year
that is equivalent to i think
representative clutier has always said
12 to 15
or somewhere in that regular bills
because what it is
it's a 140 plus or minus million dollars
worth of bonding um
of state money for capital improvements
across the state
the governor will give us that um his
proposal on that
on the 15th of february by law he has to
give it to us not later than the 15th of
february
along with the operating budget at which
point
um i will get it turned into a bill
and then we begin to hold public
hearings on
um that we will hear from
virtually every state agency
not only on what is in the the capital
budget is proposed by the governor
but also what they would like to have in
it
and when i say agency it's not just
state agencies we'll hear from the
community college system the university
system
and some others along the way that we
have supported in the past
with with capital expenditures um just
be aware that if people reach out to you
about the capital budget you can commit
your vote on something
but you can't commit the the committee
the committee vote at the end on the
capital budget is what commits
the um committee
on what we're doing with the cup capital
budget
it will take time it will be
um we'll talk about how the hearings are
going to be conducted here in a few
minutes
but it's going to be a challenge to do
that
in the current environment hearing from
every agency
and i'm still working with the speaker
on how we we get to do that
um speaking of the capital budget
there is a long-standing tradition
within this committee
pass capital expenditure requests
outside of the capital budget
that's only so that we have a handle on
state bonding
and what our debt service will be in the
ongoing years
i know that there are two bills that are
currently assigned to the committee
that ask for that for additional capital
expenditures outside of the capital
budget we will have to deal with those
in the very near future um hopefully
before
the 15th of february and i'm guilty
because one of them i am the sponsor of
uh but um
do i have any questions about the the
and this is unusual for the committee i
will say this
because if we were sitting around the
table there would be questions and
comments
i know looks like a representative wants
to speak
barry go ahead and excuse me if i seem
informal
but during these work sessions that we
have just within
the committee um we tend to be a little
less formal um
and especially after we've gotten to
know each other and i've known
representative faulkner for more than a
couple terms now
so i i know he does not take offense
when i say barry you can
not move it uh
if you might want to go over what we're
going to hear from the treasurer in
terms of our bonding limit
and how much flexibility we actually
have to deal with that i think that
might be
a good guide
well actually the treasurer will be on
with this later this morning
um she will talk about how she
determines
the amount of money we can borrow in any
given biennium
and that deals primarily with
projections
of future revenues and what our debt
service ratio to future revenues
will be and she will get into that and
we will get another briefing from her
once we get the capital budget
and that's a sensitivity analysis
on if we borrow 6.5 percent
of anticipated revenue
or 6.7 percent how much does that change
what we can
do as far as work and it usually ends up
in the millions
when you change it one a tenth of a
percentage or whatever
i know that representative ebel asked
the treasurer to do
some sensitivity analysis two years ago
and it was amazing how much just a small
fraction of
change in the debt service ratio meant
to what we could do
as far as capital improvements were but
thank you for the question barry
thank you mr chairman um i have a
question but i don't know when the
appropriate time is to ask it
is it correct that there were several
projects that we
authorized through the capital budget
that were put on hold because of the
pandemic and do we have any sense of
what
proportion there were or how that all
worked out and
again that that may not be something
that we have an answer to right now but
i was just curious
um i do not have it in front of me i
know that representative clutier and
representative edgar and others we did
get a
um an update
as part of the capital budget overview
committee which is a statutory committee
on which we served that overseas capital
improvement
outside of of the regis regular
legislative process
yes the governor did suspend all capital
projects at the very start of the
pandemic
where it looked like we i have a cuckoo
and there is no way short of sloppy that
then i can do anything with it
uh anyways the governor did um
pause all new capital projects with very
few exceptions
at the start of the pandemic he
has been on a case-by-case basis
allowing them to proceed with either
engineering
or actual moving on to construction
i will make sure that we get the most
updated list
of that when we start because for those
that are not done
we will as the returning members know as
part of the capital budget
we have to either extend the
appropriation
for another two years or not and that
whole
it's called lapses and lapse extensions
is a whole day of of listening to
agencies
as it is but part of that is going to be
because of the pause
that was put on all of these um projects
so there will be a larger
amount i think this time around um
because i don't think even if the
contracts are let this spring
um the money will not be fully um
obligated um by the
first of july so we'll have to extend it
um but we'll get into those
details once we actually
see what the governor proposes
and then get an update from
administrative services and other
agencies
on what they have done or not done
hopefully that answered your question
karen
thank you can i ask the question sure
i don't i don't know if it's a question
for the treasurer or not but i know the
one bill
that we had that we passed funding
50 million dollars to loan to
municipalities
to remedy the pfa's
situation whether that what the status
of that is
because i mean i i think it obviously
have an impact
it i do not know with status of that as
far as letting the bonds out
um and you might be willing you might be
able to ask
the um the treasurer when she comes on
but yes it will have an impact because
all bonding impacts our
debt service ratio which then impacts on
what we can borrow for
the coming biennium and the future
so that's why we don't like to to
as i said earlier do um
stand-alone capital appropriations
because it does
work um into the whole
bonding issue which we are supposed to
be overseeing
um the other thing that some of the
returning members
may know that in one of those omnibus
bills
that was passed by the senate and the
house there was some
additional money for cte
community technical
[Music]
school in hudson
but that money was found by using money
from projects that was already completed
so it would not impact on on
the overall um debt servicing within the
state
okay the second major item
on bit typical bills is in the second
year
of the biennium and that is
the um 10-year transportation plan
um it always comes in the even numbered
years
and in that we deal with all facets of
transportation
within the states not just roads bridges
highways
it's rail aeronautics
bus transportation all of those types of
issues
and we will be getting a briefing
at some point from the
department of transportation on
their function in all of this as well as
their challenges with
funding um
with with this um and some of that will
deal with what happens in washington d.c
because a significant portion unlike
almost all of it
for what we do comes from the federal
highway fund
and so we will have to
to get into that and we will get a
briefing on that
this first year
and then again in the second year
because everything that we do
people are going to be asking you what's
going on with transportation
and highways and bridges what why the
bridge in my town isn't fixed
or when it will be fixed um
those types of of things um
and then all bills dealing with changes
to the highway fund which by
constitution is um
primarily um the road toll our gas tax
as most
people call it and registration fees
that the state collects goes into a
highway fund which can only be used
for roads and
associated
things such as staffing of dot and the
rest
and also any changes to the turnpike
fund
which is collected as as everybody knows
at the
toll plazas throughout the state
all of that comes to us there is at
least
one bill in the house
i do not know where it is because i it
has not been assigned a
a bill number yet that deals with a
a road usage fee i do not know whether
that will come to us
first or go to ways and means first
in the past it has come to us first to
see how it fits in
to working up the highway fund and then
gone to ways and means
but i do not know the chair of ways and
means is the primary sponsor
of that bill there is a similar bill
um in the senate do not know where that
will go
but if it comes over we may be we may
see that
in the second half of this year um
and we can talk about that if and when
those bills show up in committee
and then um we have bills that name
things
um you know to to name the bridge
in bedford the the john a graham
memorial bridge
um not yet guys not yet
but those would come to us
if it is a state bridge state road state
highway
or state building because they are state
property
and we are the committee that it comes
to
for approval it's fairly simple
but a lot of them are
memorials to somebody who has passed and
has had
significant contribution to our nation
our state
or even their own town so
be on the lookout for those and then
finally
as i read in the charge uh monuments and
memorials
um we do get those
there are not a lot of of new ones being
built
the most recent one is the um
the one across from the the state house
for
um uh what's the what's his name
somebody yeah thank you
um that is in front of the state library
um and so we have to to look at those
and how they're going to be funded the
one over
odeon point was funded privately
most of them are there's one in front of
uh dot on hazen drive
that is being raised the money freight
is being raised
uh privately as well so it depends but
we will get them
i have not seen any right now
today without the capital budget
there are only five bills that have been
assigned to the committee
two of them deal with uh capital
requests
um one melissa deals with uh
turnpike uh toll plazas in merrimack
sound wall in uh bedford
guess who put that one in ah but
um if those are the five and i forget
what the other one is i
if they're on the website you can look
and see what they are
and read them ahead of time but if we do
not
get any others um my intention is to
hear all five of those
in one day um
and hopefully it it will be we'll get
into hybrid meetings
in in a bit but one long day
the speaker has given the chairman
the authority to do same-day
executive sessions it will be my
intention to do that
if the committee can agree
on a way to handle each bill
so that we're not coming back in a
second time just to have
a half hour executive session
it is a change from normal house
practice
where you usually have at least a week
between
the hearing and the rest um
if there is controversy on any bill i
will do that
but i think that given the circumstances
at the moment
if we can either um
at the end of of a bill or the end of a
couple bills like
handle both of those for capital
requests in one exact
executive session after hearing both of
them um
we do that and move on and that will
clear the deck
before we get the capital budget which
so we won't have anything hanging over
us
unless we get a second committee bill
now second committee bills the returning
members all know what that is
it is one committee will hear the bill
make a recommendation of the house if it
passes
if there is another policy or financial
interest
that has to be resolved by a different
committee
it gets sent to a second committee we
occasionally
um are either the first committee as i
said
like on the anything changing or raising
the
the gas tax would go come to us and then
go to ways and means
sometimes it's the other way around it
will go to
uh transportation or
something like that and then come to us
but those are always on a deadline
and so we'll have to just be cognizant
of that and i will let you know which
ones are
have to be done early the rest are done
within the
the guidelines that we agreed to
at our last session as far as deadlines
for
working on bills and those are printed
calendar notices i mentioned that
earlier all meetings
to include like this one or any work
sessions that we have
on the capital budget have to be noticed
in the
in the calendar so look there every week
either
online or if you've elected to get it
sent to you please read it
or it's important
that we be here um
and we'll go into anything on on just
the kind of work that we do anything
else
anything that i forgot the types of
things
yeah representative jack uh thank you
it's probably worth mentioning on second
committee bills uh that you're only
supposed to
uh examine the issue that brought it to
the second committee and not the entire
bill
that that is correct um the one
committee that is notorious for
um changing things once it gets to them
changing policy
is the finance committee they are
supposed to look looking
at whether or not it is fiscally
responsible or
uh there's a capability to do it but a
lot of times
depending on who the chairman is we'll
also look at the policy and change the
policy that came out of
a different committee which kind of
irritates some committee chairman
when that happens that has not happened
to us
most of our bills are standalone
to include the capital budget and the
10-year plan they do not go to finance
as a second committee so we are
responsible for
um there
as i said you will find when we start
going back in
that our com committee assistant has
placed bills
normally i would say don't take them
home because you're going to need them
again
but since we're not going to be able to
get at your
personal drawer you're going to have to
take them back
and forth um so just plan on that
um public committees uh public hearings
are all public there is no you know some
people hear executive session
that's still public and we'll talk about
executive session in a moment
but it is still a public meeting and the
public is entitled to be there
um the public hearing no quorum
is required a quorum in our case
is 12 members if there's only two of us
we can still hold the public hearing not
ideal
and we would i would appreciate and i
think all of the members would
appreciate
uh maximum participation because that's
where you get the information about
the bill from both the sponsors
the critics the supporters and
the agency if it has an impact on an
agency
and you need all of that to actually
make up your mind on how you're going to
support
or not support a particular bill or how
you think it should be amended
so please i i ask that you make an
effort
to to make committees um
and i'll just leave it at that
um yes i think
i missed that one who you know you take
it up and do time but
there's some talk about combined
committee hearings
would that apply to first and second
committees or or how would that work or
is that not relevant to what we're
talking about
um what was that again barry there's
some talk about having
larger hearings committees you know
two committees participating my
discussions
with with the speaker's office have been
that
that rule that we approved
would allow the speaker to say for
example
public works and ways and means are now
a combined committee
with one chairman and the rest to hear
um the road usage fee bill um
and not have first and second committee
i know in the past
um speakers have said meet together and
vote separately
this rule would allow it to be one vote
from and one committee report
so we're working on that
i don't see us involved in a lot of
those
um maybe one or two and if so
um i can imagine that we would have that
in in representatives hall
or via zoom one of the two um
because you start talking 40 people or
50 people
in a room there's none big enough other
than repsol
um but that's that's where we are
um so that i as i said a quorum is not
needed
but it helps if you've been there um
when we get to the executive session
rather than trying to catch up on uh
what was said during the hearing
um typically the way it works
um and i'm probably putting with those
of you who have been
on various committees before to sleep
but
the sponsor or sponsors of the bill
will come in and introduce the bill to
uh the members of the committee and then
take questions on
why the bill has been put in
we hear from the sponsors first and then
members of the public both pro and con
now if the governor or the chief justice
uh
come in they're obviously going to go to
the head of the line
as a matter of respect for um
for their heading up the um
um other branches of of
government or if the speaker comes in i
will probably
defer let him speak as well
but i don't expect that to happen i
expect those directions to come in
private um
but that works and i want to talk
because it's important that
you have are entitled to ask questions
of everybody who testifies
they do not have to answer your question
and most of them will but
private citizens who are there to make a
point
they don't know the background they
don't know the rest
um don't engage them in a debate
um that that's true of anybody
we're not when you ask them the question
it's not to engage in debate is to
elicit
information to clarify something in your
mind
debate comes in our executive session
amongst ourselves
so please
[Music]
getting back to decorum and that's part
of the decorum
you just go you know you mentioned that
xyz will happen if uh what if
this bill doesn't happen what what is
the um
consequence that those types of things i
would also like to see a whole lot
fewer of um
speeches from members that end in would
you believe
too many members use that as a
mechanism to make a speech while
somebody is testifying
you know it's sort of like well i don't
agree with your position
and i think x y and z is not very good
uh would you believe that that's not a
question of
the person who is um testifying so
please it's solicit information
and if you want to argue when we get
into exact session
all questions are directed through me
i will recognize you if you have a
question of a particular speaker
raise your hand um make or
make sure that the vice chair or the
clerk or
the the ranking member no they'll all
make sure that i know that you want to
ask a question
i'm knowing all of you and i'm sure that
nobody's going to be shy
about making sure that i know that you
want to ask a question
so that is helpful
and if there are multiple people trying
to ask a question of the same
person who is who is testifying
i will try to take them in order you get
one question
and then if you have a follow-up you ask
me
um for permission to ask a follow-up you
don't just have the floor
once i call on you that's a house rule
that's a long-standing house policy as
well
it just keeps control of the committee
hearing
and i would ask for your cooperation in
that
if you start to ask a second question i
will probably say
something along the lines of you have a
follow-up representative
um just to remind people that that they
do
have a responsibility to ask the chair
whoever happens to be in the chair
for for permission to ask her question
if you ask a question that has already
been asked and answered
i will probably bite my tug and not be
sarcastic
but please don't do that it has happened
not too badly in this committee but in
others that i've sat in
you know they've answered the question
and then two
um ten minutes later while they're
answering another one a representative
will ask the exact same question
it's just um not very professional
because it shows they haven't been
paying attention
and it also wastes time which i don't
think any of us want to do
i mean we get the big bucks but uh
okay anything about um
people testifying asking questions um
no speeches that from any or anybody
else want to chime in
or isn't that included or did you have
something uh yes
i mean the question is too i know
because of covet 19
are people want to come in and testify
going to be allowed to do so remotely
um i was going to get to that when i got
to
i have a whole discussion on hybrid
meetings okay short answer is
um yes the public will testify
via um a remote platform
that's still being worked out
the committee will come in to
a double room so we can be socially
distanced
as much as possible members themselves
will have the option at least initially
to come in remotely and participate that
way
um you know especially you know like
right today
representative philadelphia would
probably have not been uh welcome
uh in the committee uh not that we
wouldn't want to see him but because of
his health situation
so people are gonna have to make those
decisions
at some point either later in the
this calendar year or next year
once things are under control with
vaccine and everything
we will go back to our traditional way
of
holding in-person testimony in-person
hearings
for right now the health and safety of
not just the members
and staff that at the house but also
of the general public who want to
testify as
all of us know who have been there if
all
20 house committees are meeting there
are several hundred people roaming the
halls
at any given time so that it's just not
conducive to
the general health situation um
at the moment but we'll talk a little
bit more about that
representative jack uh thank you mr
chairman uh
if same-day execs are going to be more
in the nature of regular order
we're going to have to be a lot more
sensitive to needing quorum
even for public hearings because there
might be an exec and you wouldn't want
to miss a vote
just because you weren't there thank you
that was next time when i was going to
get to exact session
because in the calendar every calendar
for every committee will have a
statement that
says executive session may
follow at any time during the day or
words of that effect
so if you are not there you don't get to
vote later
it's when the question is put by the
chair
which then um
will talk about exec sessions and the
rest and
absences in a little bit but i thank you
for bringing that up marty because it is
important
i mean i can imagine that that first
meeting we have
which will not be until after the 25th
of january
that's a given that i heard that from
the speaker yesterday
because they are still trying to make
sure that they have the uv
lights and air exchangers and everything
working within the community rooms
so but that will be five bills
you know it'll probably be another long
day um
with the exact sessions that i would
like to do on the same day
um normally just for
for the new members um there's no
action on the bill on the same day that
it's heard um
any member to do some additional
research
or the rest it's usually a week or two
following
and noticed in the calendar
so please
this will be different um one other
thing
about conflicts of interest
you all
probably know that in house sessions
if you have a conflict of interest you
have to declare it
and before we vote on a bill it
should be the same in committees
i noticed that one member talked about
doing construction for
agencies that money comes through the
capital budget
um so you're going to have to make a
determination on whether or not that is
a
conflict of interest and file something
with
the clerk's office that you will or will
not participate on the final votes
in committee on the capital budget
if in fact you do do that kind of work
for whatever agency and that's true of
any other bill that may come before us
or come before you and
on the hill i just bring that up because
i heard it
as we were talking earlier mr speaker
yeah chairman in anticipation of my
election
i've not entered into any con new
contracts with the state
okay i i just bring it up because it's a
good way to get
people to to throw mud at you
that you're voting to enrich yourself i
understand that i'm i'm trying to work
my way
out of the construction business as my
years build up here but uh i i
was well aware that before right all
right i i appreciate it but
i felt it was incumbent upon me to to
to point that out because it's important
all right that was let's talk about
hybrid meetings for a moment
um hybrid meetings
guidance at the moment his intention
is to have committee members come into
concord
into a double room probably just one day
a week for each committee
because there's not enough technology to
run all 20 committees at once
we can probably do four or five
a day any given day four or five
committees
committees will be meeting monday
through friday
i do not know what day we will be
meeting
at this point um i'm fighting for
midweek and i've also told the speaker
that once we start on the capital budget
we're going to need more than one day to
meet
because it it just has to be
done with every agency on what they are
doing
so the committee will meet in person
those committee members who feel
unsafe and do not wish to come into the
to the room can
come in via remote access
but um i will leave that up to you to
decide which
um the public will be given
notice in the house calendar
um on how to either call in
or join via zoom um
to give their testimony and
um and present information
the harder part for us and the public
especially if it's just private citizens
is getting their
[Music]
any written information that they have
out to the committee members how do i
how do
i and we get that in and how does it get
distributed
to committee members if we're in person
that's easier
we just get it xerox and put it on on
your desk
but if you're coming in remote it's
going to have to be
um emailed to you or some other fashion
made available all of those questions
are still
still being worked on um and i know
representative evil could tell me she
probably knew how to do it but
because we've talked about this before
but
it is going to be a challenge um
and because
coming in remote we'll have to take a
roll call
of those coming in remote via voice at
the start of each
um
session uh session day that we're there
committee day
just so that it's annotated on the
committee records of who was
in committee that day normally we just
sign a sheet
that gets passed around and everybody
signs it and that's your attendance for
the day
but if you're coming in remote we'll
have to make a special note of that
doing it by zoom as i said
will pose some problems i have asked the
speaker as i said
on the capital budget to allow the
agency
heads or their designated representative
to come in and testify in person to the
committee
only because they always bring reams of
paper and
i don't want to print it out at home
personally
but it is also useful
to sit there and see body language and
and the rest
he has not the speaker has not given me
the okay for that
yet but we're still six weeks out from
being
being able to start on the capital
budget
um for
the hybrid um i will be designated as a
co-host
as will um one or two other members
i have asked the vice chairman to help
i've also asked representative jack to
help with some of the technology issues
and and looking um the reason i asked
representative jack
one as we said earlier it's collegial
and we don't really look at party
plus he was the clerk for hillsborough
county when we were trying to do all
this
remotely fairly successfully i will have
to say
um but thank you both for for stepping
up
there will be um
some limited tech support um
but not a lot um because we're not
hiring a lot of new people to handle
this
for a short term thing um committee
clerk still you have to record
the information of attendance at the
beginning of the meeting
um to include those in attendance
and then just normal getting the uh
the notes from any hearing to the
committee assistant
typing up and inclusion in the
record um committee members well i
talked about this earlier
one email so that you get the
the request for um any
um zoom meeting that maybe happened or
if you want to do that
um the information that is in the
house calendar is generic
it will get you into the meeting but
will not get you
in as a participant um the zoom
um for panelists as they're called
comes unique to your email
before the day of the hearing
please let myself or the vice chair
or for the other party
and now just let myself for the vice
chair know if you're going to be
attending in person or remotely so that
we can figure out what to do
um we'll talk about exact sessions in a
little bit because that's a little bit
different
um and um
that's so that i know who to look for i
mean i can look and see if you're not at
a
chair and say okay where is uh
representative mcconkey
oh yeah he's on the zoom and not here
please don't share that unique zoom
um that will be given out to members of
the committee
legislative staff um
[Music]
and you'll get an automatic um
second invitation the morning of the
meeting
as hopefully everybody did this morning
um
okay um uh
if you're participating remotely it's
still you know
decorum is important um so that we're
not
talking over each other muting unmuting
is important we will not
access and you cannot access
the chat or question and answer feature
of the zoom platform
if you look at the bottom right now it's
not there
that's to preclude um any questions
about
right to know and open meetings so that
we are not trying to do something
um in the background as
always um even happens in when we're in
person
um there are emails and texts and and
the rest that people
sometimes are sending but that's up to
you
but if it goes on to something like the
chat
or a email to all members if
discussing the status of a bill
it becomes part of the bill record and
right to know so please let's refrain
from
hitting reply all um to say
you know please vote no or i don't you
know do it in public and i think that's
all that
anything about the remote hearings
representative evil
okay thank you very much mr chair um
so when we're talking about the hybrid
meetings i understand that there are
real ventilation
problems with the lob and
in the short term there are going to be
portable
ventilation machines that will be put in
the rooms
they're going to be double rooms and i
guess all i would say is that i hope
that you'll be able to provide as much
information as possible
you know scientific backup or whatever
to make
members who are deciding whether to join
in a high
in person or remotely
comfortable in their decision
i will pass on any information that i
have
scientific information from a history
major i would look at
as suspect but what i have i
i will make sure that the committee has
um and and again it's going to be up to
each individual member
um to decide whether or not
to attend that way at least in the short
term
until i
i wouldn't even hazard a guess as to
when
things will return to normal as the
speaker said in his
one of his latest messages to all of us
yes you have your seat um assignment but
i can't tell you when you'll ever sit at
it um it's the same with with this
i can't ever tell you when we're going
to be
um fully in person
for committee meetings um
john you're muted okay yes thank you i'm
sorry
uh do you have so you don't you have any
idea mr chair
chairman when you'd schedule this
hearing uh would it be not until at
least the
last week in january even into february
right now the speaker has
asked all of the chairman not to
schedule
any hearings next week okay
so the week of the 25th at the earliest
and i would like to do that either that
week or the first week in february
um depending on what we can work out
with um
[Music]
what day and the and the rest to handle
the five
bills that we have in committee at the
moment
if any more come in maybe both weeks i
don't want to do
you know seven or eight hours um if
people
are there but if if it's only five or
six
i think that we can handle them all in
one day
one longish day but it's better than
coming in two or three times in a week
it's just we shall see not all of the
bills have been given bill numbers or
assigned to committees
the clerk's office this week
we shall see but you
do not plan on anything next week the
week of the 18th
so the week of the 25th i i do intend
if at all possible to have a meeting
um so we shall see but
as soon as i get it and i get the date
confirmed
um um i will email the the committee so
everybody has as much knowledge
okay i mentioned okay
let's see hello peterson representative
peterson
thank you mr chair i have a question um
will committee members be allowed to
vote remotely
using zoom yes thank you
um that's the whole purpose of the
hybrid um
so that will
be that way and it won't change much i
know that
um on some of the committees that
statutory committees that that i was on
that representative clutier was on where
normally we would
always chair normally we'd do the voice
vote
we had to do everything roll call but in
committees
and exec sessions we do a roll call
anyways so
it's just you're gonna have to to be
there and say yay or nay
representative newman you had a question
or comment yes
yeah thank you mr chairman if any of us
know that we have a
scheduling conflict say the week of the
25th and thereafter for a
an appointment of some sort should we
let you know
so maybe that will help you make a plan
or do you have to make a plan
irrespective of anything we've got going
um i hate to say it this way
but given the limited access that each
committee will have
to um committing rooms
um and may only be public works you have
thursdays
in in a room um okay we're gonna have to
go with that
um so you know
if you're gonna be gone for a whole week
i i i not gonna be able i don't think to
to work it to for individual members
um but we can
see what we can work on okay
and i'll just continue like i'm i'm sure
i'm not the only one but
i've got a dental appointment coming up
and i and i'm sure it's scheduled in the
morning
some it's coming up in february and
something else so
if and and frankly given everything
i mean if if you've got a dental
appointment or a doctor's appointment
they're hard to get rescheduled also so
is it okay with you
if there is a conflict that we attend
late if we've got a previous thing that
was scheduled
um so you know as as always members
wander in and out as
as they want um but
if you're not if you're there and then
not there
and you miss the exact session that's
you've missed the exact session that's
the only
that's the only um downside to that
but no if you come in late that's fine
if you dial in late
you know or you have to leave early
that's always been
the practice of every committee
it is uh incumbent upon all of us as
representatives
to make uh as much of the
the hearings and exact sessions as we
can
um so please make the effort but
you're right if you've got a dental if i
haven't my dentist keeps calling me
going
uh nope you can't come in yet
so i understand the problem
thank you
okay i mentioned um works
i have a question john excuse me mr
chairman
just a couple of things um on the public
testimony the way the protocol was
before
people pre-registered if they wanted to
give testimony and then their uh
testimony was emailed out to the
committee in advance of the committee
meeting
so that way people who are attending
remotely or
whatever they're sure to they should be
sure to get the documents
and i guess i would just um i know you
will do this but i would just put in a
plea
that to make people comfortable that are
attending remotely when
we get to the hybrid format that
we all feel that we're able to
participate as fully whether we're there
remotely or in person
and i'm sure hcs is working on all those
protocols but i think
you know people are concerned about that
um they are i and they are continuing to
work
it is my understanding um that there
will be one large
screen in the room
[Music]
so that those justifying will show up on
that if they're
they're using zoom or at least their
phone number will
will show up as as it does here on these
and that brings me to uh to a piece
about
electronic devices on in the committee
um
hard to say don't use them
um but as you all know if we're sitting
around a table
and all 23 of us if we're all ever there
have a laptop popped up in front of us
you know it it is disconcerting to
anybody trying to
over zoom which is why they're bringing
screen for the committee to be able to
see everybody see the same thing
now i the clerk or the vice chair or
maybe all three
or at least the other two are going to
have to have something there
to look at the remote members
and who else is waiting to testify um
so we'll have to work on that um
to so that if say representative
newman or representative graham
graham isn't there for participating
remotely
they at least can see if they're raising
their hand or whatever
it's going to be a challenge and i don't
think any of us think that it won't be
as i said earlier i don't think any of
you are so shy that you won't say
something
that if you're being ignored um
you know a little bit more decorum when
we've got
members of the public there um and i
will not and i will refrain from saying
karen or john
or david when when it's a public hearing
work sessions are just that it is a
meeting
of the committee to work on
particular items that may be in front of
them
it is not a public hearing
the chair may invite people to come in
and provide information to the work
session
but it is not a public hearing in the
fact that the entire public can come and
say
something at that it will be listed in
the calendar and it will be listed as a
full committee work session that is the
way we will handle most of the capital
budget
as we have in the past it'll say full
community
committee work session uh 10 10 to 10
15 the adjutant general you know 10
20 to 11 o'clock
um another agency depending on what
they've got
but they will be listed and they they
are that
and they are conducted along the same
lines
as a public hearing as far as decorum
asking questions getting permission from
the chair
to ask questions of whomever is
presenting
so just be aware that those will come up
and that's important because you know
once we get into the capital budget
we do hear from every agency and we have
in the second year we have work sessions
on the
10-year transportation plan as well as
well as public hearings which are
different
we'll have we'll open in all probability
work sessions on the capital budget
before the bill is printed
um i think we've done that in the past
just so that we can get started and then
a public hearing so that people can come
in most of the agencies will wait until
their time
knowing that they have a work session
but members of the public
will come in and say their piece on
what they think the state should do or
not do
for capital improvements and how to
spend
money then we'll close that recess that
not close it
recess that until after all the agencies
have had and then we'll go into another
public hearing
and then into exact session it's
kind of convoluted i got
lost my first term on it but
found my way eventually um
any questions about work sessions
they're they are
less formal but still the decorum has to
executive sessions are just that
there are sessions amongst ourselves
to determine the fate of any particular
bill that's in front of us
we have to have a quorum a quorum in
this case being
12 or more members in attendance
physically in attendance either in the
in the room or via zoom if we're doing
hybrid
um if you know that you will not be
present
please let me the vice chair
representative mcconkey
his phone number is five two zero
520-8275
know the day before that you will not
make the executive session
so that we can get a replacement for you
i would ask that the democratic members
also
let representative clutier or
the minority office or whomever john
designates to get that um that you're
not going to be there
because to be honest and this is my
partisanship
one time showing i'm not going to work
real hard on getting democratic
replacements
if you're not going to be an executive
session
all replacements must be appointed by
the speaker
i can't just go out in the hallway nor
can
representative clutier uh go out the
hallway grab the next
republic of the democrat and say fill in
for
uh representative uh
whomever um but if the speaker appoints
them
they become voting members for the
most times we don't need them because
we've already reached consensus on what
we're going to do with the bill
and if it ends up being you know
21 to 2 so be it
i'd rather have it 23-0 but
if the overwhelming majority of the
committee is supportive
just so everybody knows and
those who have been chairs know this as
well
i can adjourn the executive session at
any point
where i don't think i'm going to get the
just the power of being the chair up
until the time
that the question is put to the members
for a vote
if two minutes before that happens
um it looks like the motion that is on
the floor that i may or may not want
is not going to go the way that that i
think it should
i can i can adjourn the exact executive
session to another time
and then work on it we may still be the
same outcome the next time but
that is one of the powers that the chair
has
the other thing that i need to point out
about executive sessions everybody knows
this
is that there is no public import
without my approval
it is not another executive session
and it's not another public hearing if
you have specific questions
um post them to me and i will decide
whether or not to pose it to a sponsor
or agency
or whomever this does not mean that
you're not free to go out
and ask questions of sponsors lobbyists
or whomever
before the exact session to try to get
your question answered
after the public hearing but
i don't want to turn exec sessions into
um a second public hearing if at all
possible
all amendments that are being proposed
and any one of you can propose an
amendment to any bill we have
has to be prepared by
[Music]
and we will get
copies printed and brought down to
i think everybody knows what the basic
motions that can be heard in in a
executive session are thought to pass
out to pass his amendment an expedient
to legislate
or retain and retain is only for this
year
what that means is we will hold the bill
for additional work in the
summer or fall and then come back in the
fall
for a uh final executive session on the
bill
so the house can vote on it in next
january january of
22.
for in order for an amendment to come
forward
there has to be a positive motion i
ought to pass
motion on the floor in the committee
just because you have an amendment
prepared
doesn't mean that the committee's going
to take it up if there is
not um and not to pass motion or
i get to call who makes the
motion and
as many times
as some of the returning members will
know prior
11. um
it's not quite right um what is going on
uh um the chair
i can turn and go and i believe
representative mcconkey has a motion to
me
um and i know that um
one previous speaker used to do the to
me
a lot not no and why not knowing i was
making the motion
um but just know that i get to
pick who who it is um
if you make the motion you have to
write the committee report for the house
gallon
um and if there's going to be a minority
report
i approve both the minority and the
just for factual information
and then it gets get sent into the clerk
that's exec sessions and
that's a couple of other points
any questions about exec sessions mr mr
chairman
yeah uh yeah i just wanted to say too
that
if a member is absent from my caucus
uh and i'm for some reason not available
they should contact representative edgar
who's the deputy ranking member and a
former vice chair of the committee
and you and the vice chair mcconkey
should know that as well
all right thank you and good job very
thorough
well it's it's harder to do with this
because i'm doing all the talking
without people
you know nudging me going did you
remember this did you talk about this
um so anyways
you're doing a good job i mean it's
better you than me i think right now
um two other things i'd like to mention
um
bradley greenland are you on
yes i am all right brad is our
committee researcher researchers serve
as resources for the entire committee
and resources that request him for
for information or help
goes through the chair he he works for
several committees um
so in order for um him to know that
it's actually coming for the entire
committee and not just an
individual
please let me know in all probability
i'm gonna say yes
but just um do that brad where'd you
come from
i know you're relatively new oh yes so
i started back um in the middle of march
just before everything shut down
um before that um i was
i worked for the department of safety um
and especially the state police
before coming over here and um
i've been from in new hampshire my
entire life i was born in nashville i
grew up in merrimack
um and then now currently live in
manchester
thank you i just wanted people to know
who who
the uh the person was who's may
at some point be sitting in the back of
the room taking notes or when we asked
to get things
um committee assistants um
are our administrative assistants to um
several committees um they are not there
for
um committee members to have
things typed mailed any of that kind of
of stuff um when representative mills
is finished after each hearing with
his handwritten notes he hands them to
the committee assistant to be typed up
and put in the proper order
so we will be sharing one um
ours this term for the short term
anyways
we'll be sharing with ways and means um
she's a long-standing
assistant over there i just got an email
from her about two minutes ago
saying she wanted to introduce herself
as the one who will be helping us
um so david i'll i'll forward that to
you
and that's it if we're in the building
there
is on the fourth floor if we get it open
um computer support
all um letterhead all that kind of stuff
that you may need
on the fourth floor of the lob and there
is wi-fi both in the state house
and the lob that members can access
um so that kind of
it in a nutshell any questions of
what the committee does how we work
and it's a work in progress as far as
hybrid
and and the rest but best i can give you
okay if anybody needs to take a break
do that do not i'm not shutting off or
anything
because we're going to go right into a
presentation
from the legislative budget assistant
on the capital budget process
outline of how the process works
but i'll bring him up in a minute but if
you have to go
mark take over for a minute i have to
sounds good i am going to
be back in just one moment all right
then
thank you if anyone else wants to um
attend to some matters uh please feel
free to
and uh i think we're gonna move on with
the presentation a couple minutes so
you
good
[Music]
um
so
okay
i'm back while we're in a break the
chairman's clock seems considerably
nicer than the prior chairman's clock
good morning wrestling graham good
morning committee
good morning just give it a couple
minutes as people come back
they've been we've been sitting here for
two hours so no that i totally
understand
so whenever everybody's ready ready um
there is one piece of decorum i forgot
to mention to all the members
if we're in the building in a committee
room
there is no food or drink at the
um table um
that pains me because most of the
returning members though i drink a lot
at the direction of the speaker let's
now if we are there and we take a lunch
break
you will be um allowed to eat at your
desk
um only because there's not gonna be
much open
around for you to go go eat unless you
want to go outside and
sit in the cold um but
as soon as representative mcconkey comes
and he's been here
i'd like to introduce uh what's your
official title mr shay
so i'm the deputy legislative budget
assistant okay
he's been working with us for a while he
is the one who will be
handling uh work that deals with the
capital budget
uh with us in the committee and
to to advise us on what to do he can't
tell us what to do
because it is matters of policy but he
can tell us ramifications and
what's happened before and whether or
not legal permitted to spend money
in certain ways so i've asked him to
give us
an overview of the capital budget
process
and so we understand
where we are at the current moment but
more importantly
over to you mr shea well thank you
chairman graham and committee
committee members here today just to
start i'll give you kind of a brief
overview of
the legislative budget assistant office
and and who we are
uh we're nonpartisan um the one of the
bigger
elements that we work on obviously is
the budget the operating budget and the
capital budget
um we have six people in our office
um that do this work we do it for the
house and we do it for the senate
um and we try to provide the information
to members as they request it
and provide direction you know as may be
necessary as you're going through a
process
i i specifically am assigned to the
capital budget and to ways and means for
revenue estimates
along with overseeing um the staff and
in our budget
side of the office we also have an audit
division
which um at this point i have nothing to
do with um
mike kane who's the legislative budget
assistant deals primarily with the
audit side of the house and that's
intentional um we we
try to keep a wall between us so that
they can do their work uninterrupted by
um things that we may be doing on the
budget side and working with members
um i did work on the audit side for 10
years before coming to the budget side
so i'm
very familiar with you know what happens
on that side of the house
but i just wanted to kind of talk that
through with you a little bit
um i've been doing the capital budget
the last couple of years
um so i have some familiarity with it
been doing revenues a little bit longer
and prior to that
um i dealt with the operating budget
from 2007 when i came over to the budget
side
so that's just a you know a real brief
kind of overview
of who we are who i am um
and what we're gonna we're going to
provide to you some of the other
services in our office that you may be
familiar with is when you see a bill
with a fiscal note on it
that comes from our office so if you've
ever have a question or concern about a
bill of yours or a bill that you're
involved with that has a fiscal note
or may not have a fiscal note you think
it should uh please contact our office
and
and um you know we can have a discussion
with you as to why
the bill may or may not have had a
fiscal note and if it does have a fiscal
note how to end it up with that
particular fiscal note
um so that being said i'm
going to share my screen i believe brad
sent you the presentation in an email
but i was going to
bring it up on the screen because i
wanted to be able to maneuver around
on our website as well to show you some
information that is available
electro on our website so that if you
have questions after the fact you may be
able to access it
so just one second here as i
so hopefully what you're seeing right
now
is the general court web page
so i'm going to scroll down that and
you'll see the legislative budget
assistant
is on the left left hand side in the
and this is our website and as i
mentioned we have a budget division in
audit division
going down this left side column the
four committees we staff
this fist are the fiscal committee
there's a performance audit oversight
committee
long-range uh capital planning and
capital budget overview
so those are four committees that we we
do provide staff for and i'll make
mention
a little bit more about capital budget
overview and long range at the end of my
presentation
so if you come to our website you click
into the budget division
you're going to see a a line that says
budget
and revenue documents and you're going
to see
three areas as you follow my mouth the
operating and capital budget
and i apologize i'm turning my head
because i'm looking at another screen as
i do this
um
so right now for fiscal for the fiscal
22 and 2023 operating in capital budget
documents that we have um loaded up
would be
the presentation i'm going to open up in
just a moment
the governor's capital budget hearing
documents which occurred
back in june and then there's uh
two other documents which are status
updates of the capital budget that was
passed in 2019
which i am hovering over right now and
i'll go back to those after the
presentation
so here we are with the the capital
budget presentation
this is the contact information um you
know as as everybody's fully aware
um we're limitedly in the office at this
time
in fact for the next week or so we've
been asked not to go into the office
um so the best way to contact us is
through emails
we do check our phone numbers uh our
phone lines on a regular basis but an
email is much easier
um particularly if we're on a remote
call sometimes we can
um respond to an email as we're on that
and take care of an issue that you might
so the next page is just the table of
contents of what's contained in this
particular document
and i'm going to go through but not
necessarily through every single
item that's in here i may go kind of
go over some of these rather quickly
because it's not necessary to get a lot
but this first part is rsa93 the statute
that
um basically starts the the capital
budget process
so if you're not familiar with the
capital budget process it actually
started
um back in april
time frame for the agencies so
they have been they were instructed at
that time to think about capital
projects that they needed and needed to
submit something
um by the end of um by may 1st and then
by the end
of may a document was provided to the
governor
that he then had to have budget hearings
on before the end of june
those did occur and as i pointed out
those those documents that agencies
brought to that
meeting are available online so you're
able to look at that
once that occurred the governor
along with the director of public works
and several other individuals will
look at the various projects that are
brought forward by agencies
and identify with those that they think
need further work or detail
to be considered for the 2223 capital
budget
so that is done by the department of
administrative services uh
bureau of public works where they go in
and refine the numbers um
look at issues that may may not have
been considered by the agency as they're
putting
uh together the project the cost and
what they need to do
and then they establish a book and it's
a
it's called the capital improvement book
program book i have a
copy i have a hard copy right here i
have hard copies for all the members
they're sitting in my
office i just have to figure out how to
and from that they work and put together
the governor's capital budget the
governor's capital budget will come out
by february 15th the operating budget in
the capital budget are released
and that's what you see down right there
is that's when the governor needs to
the capital budget is considered a
six-year
plan even though the appropriations
um potentially could lapse after two
years and that's something that your
committee
often looks at to see doesn't is there
an extension necessary for a project or
did it get completed within the first
two years
and if you're going to extend it you may
want information from an agency as to
why
um and that's something again i'll kind
of talk about that as we get through
this
this document there are other
places in statute where the capital
budget comes up for instance the
lakeshore
uh redevelopment planning commission you
know there was
a segment of their statute that said
that they could submit information
for capital purposes in the 20 20
to the 2020 2021 capital budget
um the ctes which are at the schools
um there's language in here related to
that so that's what these rsas relate to
i just want to include them
they're for your leisure not necessarily
something that we need to talk about in
terms of process at this time but
if you see the governor's capital budget
in february and you're wondering
how did this end up in there there may
have been a statutory direction to
include it in the budget
there may not be but i just here are a
few of the statutes you may need to
so and i apologize for the uh the
scrolling
so this page here it's page eight of the
presentation
that is kind of a one pager to show you
the process
um and where you know when it starts and
when it ends
so as i mentioned the agencies that
started this process before may 1st they
had to have information ready by may 1st
the governor had information provided by
may 31st
and then he held hearings by the end of
june and since then there's been efforts
to to consolidate some of the projects
or look at some of the projects that
they that were being proposed
and include them with further detail in
in the capital improvement
uh program document come february 15th
the uh capital budget will then be in
the possession of the house
and you'll have until crossover which is
typically the end of march beginning of
april to
make all your decisions as it relates to
the capital budget
um and then as i heard represent graham
mentioning earlier
you know as part of the process we will
help you
decide which agencies to bring into
before the committee to discuss what
their
projects are and what they're requesting
and what could happen
if you can't fully fund something or if
you think there should be another
project in its place
so we would help coordinate the agencies
to come in and do that
i say we um i should mention too where
we are
limited in our staff there may be times
i don't expect
it at this moment but there may be a
time when i can't make a meeting that
you have because i'm double or triple
booked because of
other meetings i might need to attend we
may send somebody else from our office
just to represent us and to help the
committee get through whatever work they
and then once the house is done with its
process and votes the capital budget out
it goes over to the senate
they go through a similar process where
they work on it typically
the capital budget is house bill 25
um so that is is an easy way if you ever
want to search
going backwards in in the um bills if
you look for previous house bill 25s
they typically are
your capital budget so you can see you
know what the capital budget was from
or 2017 um you know 200
2005. you could go back and pick them in
that way
once the senate completes its process
they'll vote
they'll vote out their capital budget
and if it's anything like the last time
there'll be agreement already between
the two committees on what was um
changed by the senate and
you'll you would not have to go to a
committee a conference
but that is the last step that the
legislature would take as a committee
conference and typically with the
capital budget the reason you have a
committee a conference
um isn't so much to that you're in total
disagreement on what was
done by the senate it's more to make
sure that nothing is in error
and to give you kind of one last chance
to say okay are we all good with what's
in this capital budget
we're okay to let it go um
i there was limited changes between the
house and the senate this last time so i
think that that
helped eliminate the need for a
committee a conference for that
particular budget
and then hopefully the governor would
sign anything that the legislature
adopts
by the end of june and then that capital
budget would take effect so that's
essentially what this page is showing
you
and here is just a a picture of the
docket for the capital budget in 2019
you can see that the committee starting
on the 6th of
march had a number of uh work sessions
some of these would may have been um
with agencies some of them may not have
had agencies in there
depending on where you were in the
process but we again we will help you
schedule the agencies you need to have
in
and how many times you need to have them
in so you may talk to someone initially
about their capital projects and you may
need to bring them back in
to further flush out what's going on
with it
or if there were questions after the
fact
so one of the services or one of the
things that our office will do
is provide you a we call it a compare
report
so you can see column c that's the
governor and what he had
he had proposed for his capital budget
and it's structured by agency and the
name of the capital project
and then how it's funded is in column b
so f obviously is federal fund bg would
be your general fund bonds
and then there's a bo with your bonds
others so agencies such as liquor
former dread so escaping me their title
right uh
department of natural and cultural
resources so they may have other funding
sources that
that are used to take care of projects
such as the park fund
um and you'll see them as bond other and
then you also have highway funds which
would be at the end of this
we would update this at each phase and
where there was no committee a
conference there isn't a column f but
we would typically have a committee a
conference column to show you what the
final negotiations were
in this case the senate capital budget
which was adopted by the senate was
really
the last change in this particular
document
the grayed out rows are the changes that
occurred in the senate
from the house and in some cases it was
just a note that was added in other
cases it was the value
and this document typically runs 10 15
pages
so typically your house bill two house
bill 25
will be divided into sections and the
highway funds will be separated out from
the general funds
um and that's what you're seeing here
section two
is the department of safety and
department of transportation where
they're showing you their highway funds
that they would like to bond
there are some um for for example
department of safety
may have general funds matching highway
funds to take care of something so they
may have a project split between the two
and um i think if i go up you'll see
that
troop c renovation is in both places
it's because there's there's money from
both
types of funds being used to pay for
and then on the bottom of the um
document you'll find the totals as it
relates to
then you'll find the totals for the into
the entire capital budget
and the number that tends to be the one
that
is generally focused on is the total
bonds
um funded with general funds
so here we ended up just under 125
million
the governor based on the debt
affordability information provided by
the treasurer who i believe you're going
to be hearing from
after me will come up with a a number
that they believe is
a good number during that 2019 capital
budget they started 120 million
the committee felt comfortable um after
talking with the treasurer and looking
at the number of projects that were out
there to
move closer to 125 million by the time
so that that's the compare document and
then the next document
in the in the uh presentation is the
actual capital budget for 2019.
so this is the the current capital
budget that we're involved with
i included in the document just as a
kind of a one-placed
uh resource if you happen to look at
you're wondering what ended up happening
and as i mentioned there'll be
multiple sections for the capital budget
section one will typically be all those
projects that are going to be funded
through general fund um bonding
and then you can see by agency you know
how busy it is but you see how
what what the projects are and how
they're being funded
but what also is in the house bill 25
are
other sections that help make this work
so i'm just gonna scroll down
so obviously there's footnotes in here
and sometimes um
that's just to designate that the
funding source
is when it's another funding source what
that funding source is
so that there's no confusion other times
there may be direction on
for instance if you're buying a vehicle
you don't want it to be bonded for 20
years the the committee would prefer it
be bonded for only 10 years there may be
direction included in
the footnote around that appropriation
so as i go so right now it's that we're
seven pages into it we're still looking
at the appropriations
this is we're through the highway fund
the university system
um this this current capital budget the
the 2021 capital budget um
established uh appropriations over the
next
three biennium and the first was for
the focus on the spalding hall which i
believe is their science building
and then they have hyde hall and then
the um student centers
and what they've asked for is 10 million
in 2021 which the is the current budget
then they would ask for an additional 15
million
in the 2223 and then
an additional 17 in the 2425 capital
budget
those appropriations have been made in
the 2019 capital budget so as of right
now
um the treasury would allow
the university system to ask for these
amounts to be bonded
during those time frames so unless
there's a change to the statute
or this chapter law these authorities
so other things that go on
there's some boilerplate type language
in the in the
in the bill like land accuracy
acquisition
um there's a boilerplate that's in every
section on page nine here bonds
authorized
this is actually the appropriation that
the treasury will look at
and says this is the authority that's
provided to us to actually go out and
bond
the dollars that have been appropriated
in this capital budget there's
the capital budget overview so it's a
section
so during this uh 2021 capital budget
if an agency was we'll just say it's
administrative services and they're
trying to do a
a roof replacement on a building
and they've completed another project
that is in this capital
budget and they have money left over and
it could be used to help get the roof
done because there wasn't enough
appropriated at the time they can come
into the capital budget overview
committee
and ask that that money be allowed to be
transferred into the
the roof appropriation for the capitol
building
and and that way that project could get
done and and the theory or the idea
behind that is
the legislature intended for 124 million
or almost 125 million dollars
wanting to occur for the capital budgets
uh capital projects that are listed in
that capital budget
knowing that they're typically 18 months
out before
some of these projects really get going
some of the costs associated with them
may change
so they either go up in most cases
or maybe the issue wasn't as bad as
intended as it initially thought so the
agency didn't have to spend as much
money
so this just allows for for the use of
the bonding authority to actually get
but again it's not something that the
agencies can do without permission from
the legislature they do come back to the
and then i think um representative
graham's favorite part is section
14 and these are the
i'm sorry there were some other things
that occurred with appropriations
in the 19 budget where the committee
forced to lapse on some um projects and
then repurpose those funds for other
purposes but um
section 20 is the is the section i was
referencing for represent graham
and that's the lapse extended for
projects in previous capital budgets
that's there's about 160 projects in the
2019 house bill 25 that had their
appropriations extended
when you see the next capital budget and
for 2223
there's going to be some similar number
of projects that um
will also be requested to extend their
appropriations
and there's a variety of reasons for
that
sometimes projects get delayed um you
know
the the design factor you know they
couldn't get that done in time to
meet the requirements to have a project
start
when they originally thought so they're
like okay we can get it done in 2021
but we can't complete it until 2022 and
there's
some pieces that we would need to have
the funding available for
so what the committee has done in the
past is to go through and ask the
agencies to come in and talk about the
projects they want to extend the lapses
for
just to make sure the committee
understands why that's occurring
and agrees with that but it also gives
the agencies a kind of a
second bite at the apple in case they
missed a project that they needed to
extend
or they added one that they actually got
done sooner than they thought and they
really don't need it to be extended
so then it could be closed out and and
that's a
so so again that's the bill
and that's get you through what the
current capital budget is
this next page page 41 of the
presentation
is it the summary pages from the
requests made by agencies
at the governor's capital budget
hearings in june so this first page is a
summary page
so it just has the all the agencies
listed
and across the top it has various
aspects of
of a project you know are they acquiring
land
um the construction you know engineering
and architectural work is it a computer
other equipment they might need so they
list it out across the top and they give
you a value
unfortunately what this document doesn't
show you
is what the funding source is at this
time
and then as you go down to the next page
it then breaks it out by
agency and the projects that they wanted
to fund in this case
this is doit and they're looking to fund
several
computer projects some of these are are
familiar
to cyber security it's something that
they've
asked about i think the last two or
three capital budgets and have gotten
some funding
to do that i think um you tend to see
more and more
um computer or
i.t related projects in the capital
budget because
a lot of them are costly um and so
that's where they've been instructed to
put them
years and years and years ago some of
these projects tended to be done through
the operating budget or through other
mechanisms
so now you have this issue of these
these computer projects
competing with your what i would call
your traditional capital
projects the buildings and and the
maintenance of buildings
and that's something that um you you as
members of the committee will have to
kind of decide you know how much can you
afford
to give agencies to do their their
computer type project their it-related
projects versus
administrative services it will be the
largest um agency with
projects again because they're the
central agency for the state they can't
they run most of the projects
um so they will um and they manage most
of the buildings and so that's what
their projects relate to
when you have the opportunity to look at
the capital improvement program book
it does break out administrative
services into components so you can kind
of see oh this is for the buildings this
is for the courts
this is for um their i.t the what's
called fdm
for their accounting for the comptroller
and and for the state
um so again this is just to give you
some some reference or some guide as to
you know what agencies originally asked
for
and then the last piece of this so it
goes on for a few pages
and the last two pieces that i'll
mention in this document
or the capital budget overview committee
again i made comment to them
um earlier about if there's a need to
transfer but this committee also
receives quarterly updates on um
projects so the committee will see
what's
what the status is of the various
projects um
if there's a question on a particular
capital project and
and the agency's having some issues they
may come to the capital budget overview
committee
for some guidance on that um but this is
the
and i make mention of it because uh
probably a few of you from this
this particular committee will be
assigned a capital budget overview and
or
long range so um
there is a relationship in terms of some
of the work you're doing on your your
committee in public works
and then again the other is long-range
capital planning and utilization
committee
a lot of what they deal with is the
disposal of land so land that may have
been
acquired by an agency typically
department of transportation to
either um change you know a highway or a
roadway
you know with their off-ramps on-ramps
or things like that and then
um after the project's done there's a
piece of our track of land that is
really of no use to the state anymore
but an
entity may want to purchase it
that type of activity goes before the
long-range committee for them to say
yeah it's okay to dispose of that piece
of property
the other piece the long range does a
lease agreements so agencies for
lease agreements over five years need to
get approval for that
and something the committee has seen in
the last years a lot of extensions to
leases
so it may have been at least for three
years to start with but they need to
extend it for another three years they
come before the committee
because in total the the lease would
have been longer for than five years
um so so that's it on the actual
presentation itself again it's meant to
be more of a guidebook something that
you have a question to be able to pick
that up and say
i heard i heard this mention can i find
it here
and and that's hopefully you'll be able
to the answer would be yes and you'd be
able to see it there
i don't know if anybody has any
questions about this particular document
if not i'm gonna back out of the
document
and i just want to click into the
governor's capital budget so as i
mentioned
um back in june they had hearings
and all the agencies that provided
information we put up on our website
so if you wanted to see what the
department of agriculture provided
this is their narrative to the capital
request that they're making
and so that may be useful to you as you
have time now
and you want to see what agencies were
requesting and why this will give you a
little bit more of that information
or after you get the capital budget and
you see a project got included
you may want to go back to see what what
were they originally thinking when they
the other thing that i mentioned is
under the capital budget here there's
the das which is department of
administrative services
in the last year is that the department
of administrative services public works
group
has been instructed to provide a status
update to the governor on where projects
are at
with covid and as well as other things
going on projects have been delayed in
different ways
and there was also some concern that we
didn't want to incur
you know additional debt if we could
avoid it at this time not knowing
what was happening with the pandemic and
other activities
so this report which is dated 10 30 2020
was provided to the
capital budget overview committee and um
again it's just a status update of the
projects that are in the 2019
um capital budget capital budget for
fiscal years 20 and 21
and you can see where they're at with
that
the document is a fluid document
and i've made a request of public works
to provide their most recent document it
was due to be updated the middle of
december um at this point
i have not received anything in fact
i've had no communication
back to me from requests i've made from
the
ted cupper who's the public works
director
so i i will continue to try to get an
updated document
i've also talked to the deputy
commissioner for administrative services
about
getting a electronic copy of the capital
improvement program
um he's looking into that for me
if we're able to get that we will put it
on our website as well
and it would be in this area so from
any any work that we do for this
committee going forward
on the capital budget and there's a
document involved
we'll try to include it here so you can
if you um
do have to work remotely um
you have a way to access some of the
information
that agencies may have provided or
documents that were handed out
even if you're doing a hybrid situation
there may be times when you come into
the office
or come into the committee room and you
may forget something there
hopefully you know if it's something
that we have on our website that will be
so i don't know if that's really all i
had unless there's any questions for me
mr chairman can i ask a question sure go
ahead
i was just wondering i mean you showed
us that the document there
and whether you put it up there and we
try to try to print it off
or whatever i just wondered if there was
some other way
and i'm sure you don't want to put it in
the mail
um so at this point we've been trying
to put things on our websites and we've
been emailing documents to
we've had we've part of the challenge
this document is is not um
if need be at some point we possibly
could mail it to you
um but thinking going forward if you're
thinking about agency presentations and
having those mailed to you
the issue with that is is timing so
we've had an issue even with the fiscal
committee this week we have that
meetings for tomorrow as of monday one
of the members of the committee hadn't
received
their their information their paper
information we made copies
that had been out for a week already um
so you know you've read i've seen in the
news and i'm sure you all have heard in
the news that
you know the postal service has been a
little slower with the volumes and and
with some of their workload issues um
so timing of getting something to you
may be an issue but if you're
for this particular document um we can
try to make it available in hard copy we
can leave copies in the committee room
for when people come into the committee
room um
one thing at this point we will not be
back in the office for at least the next
week or
week or so you know it would be sometime
the end of january before we
are allowed back into the office so
that um i wouldn't be able to mail
anything to you before that
well but the thing is that i was i don't
know about other members of the
committee
but um i wasn't so much concerned about
the paperwork that the agencies would
have
i mean to look at that stuff online i
don't think is a
big deal but for for this
um i am working with the speaker
about when we have the agencies come in
to talk about their portion of the
capital budget
to do it in person in front of the
committee
granted not all of the committee members
may be participating that day
but the vast majority of us probably
will
um it's gonna be
not not pleasant you know it's going to
be hard to get
stuff but as mr shea said timeliness is
the real issue of
if uh department of safety has
you know 15 pages of stuff that they
want us to read
how do you get it to everybody um
before they they come in to testify
and they may not have it before the day
before
and just a further comment um
representative abbott i mean
we're still trying to figure out how to
send you the hard copy of this document
here
so once we get some direction on how to
do that we may
at that time include the um presentation
that i
just did you know went over with you
online um
it's not that we don't want to get it to
you it's just we're we're limited in
some of our abilities at this moment
um you know getting access to the
building getting access to
print materials and it's not just the
capital budget committee that we're
trying to come up with a way to do this
we have
you know for us we have the ways and
means committee and anything they might
need
but even more so um and scary so is
is the finance committee and the
operating budget
we've had some members suggest that they
would like to see agency
budget requests in paper format which we
have in our office but they are
thousands of pages long and thinking
about how to get that to the member
um it's not something that we're feeling
comfortable in terms of trying to
uh mail or ship to to the members
um at this time it's just
so our office you know we've had
requests for various documents and and
we're trying to accommodate it through
electronic means at this time and trying
to come up with a plan to address all
the committees that might request things
from us
so that we're not treating or offering
something to one group and not another
i understand i just you know
if there was some point possible to do
that
to get it to us that's all yep
yeah well i'll definitely um like i said
once i know how we can get you the
the capital improvement program book
um i'll make sure that a copy of the
presentation today is
is uh you know attached to that you know
so that you can have that or in a folder
you know
again we we may end up putting things in
an envelope with each member's name on
it and
make it available to you when when you
can get in the building or
um you know if you have other ways to to
access it
again we just don't know at this point
and that's that's conversation
had in the last couple of days as um
we've been meeting with the various
committees that we staff and some of the
requests
and and as i uh you know finances is a
heavier lift because of the volume of
paper that they have and so we're just
trying to be consistent with what we
offer
each of the groups that we work with but
i understand it
looking at things online on a computer
when you're on a remote meeting
is challenging um i mean
nimble and quick on the computer
and uh yeah i have closed myself out of
remote meetings in an effort to try to
bring material up for um committee
members that that we're working with and
so i i understand the challenge and and
uh hopefully
you know in the near future things will
christianity can you go ahead and close
out the sure
green sharing so that we can see if
anybody has questions
yeah i do representative newman
yes yes thank you boy i'm not used to
this you have to go left to go right
and whatever um i i certainly
i can't i don't understand all of the
printing
difficulties but i can appreciate how
challenging it is to try and get stuff
printed right now the only suggest
my suggestion for what it's worth when
we took our
when many of us took our oath of office
several of us delivered them up um
personally and i know we went to the
security
um door on whatever street it is and
and a security person came out we handed
them in i don't know that if there's a
way to get material
printed if they could be in an
envelope or something and like i'm
thinking there's three of us from nashua
if one of us went up and picked
something up
i don't know about other areas and i
don't even know if that's practical or
or possible given space limitations but
that's my suggestion if we could pick up
my idea is if print material could be in
an envelope at the security office
we'd call security when we were outside
the door
they'd say here you're picking it up for
nashua whatever and and deliver it out
um i i just want to follow up my concern
with trying to go into the building
in the very near future is your
the elevator i wouldn't take now at all
and i don't know about stairwells and
hallways and whatever
despite what's going on in an actual
double room so that's why i suggested
if something could be made available we
could pick it up at a door
so represent newman in response to that
the idea is a good idea
um i just don't know if our office can
unilaterally
say that's what we're going to do for
the committees um
and so we we are trying to work with the
speaker's office and others to make sure
that
we don't create something that then is
expected by every committee
and then i don't know if security would
be able to manage that kind of of a flow
you know i want i want a paper copy of a
bill i want a paper copy of
me um so again it's not that we're
that i'm trying to be resistant to
providing you what you're asking for it
just
i want to do it in a way that doesn't
step on the toes of the other committees
essentially
i understand that yep and so if once i
get some direction i will certainly let
um chairman graham know and and
um will try to get you the information
so that you can do your work
and and understanding hard copies of
some of this is important
um we we will try to do our best to to
take care of that and try to accommodate
this committee and and the others that
we work with to
make sure you have the materials and and
and the information that you need to
um if you have to work from home or from
a remote site that you have everything
that you need
thank you do we have any other questions
on the presentation
uh mr speaker yeah
possible and i don't know what the
confidentiality
of some of these documents is but
um would it be possible to for
uh mr shea's division to send this to
like the local fedex offices where we
could pick it up they could copy it
put it in an envelope and we could pick
it up there i know it's a cost
but it's going to cost the print them
one way or another
and there are fedex offices pretty much
all over the state
i think from plymouth south yeah
so represent thompson again it's it's
we want to provide the information we
want to get it to you we just want to do
it in a fashion that is consistent with
how other documents are being provided
to members
um so we have discussed different ways
we
we talked about staples we've talked
about fedex we've talked about
um representative newman's idea of maybe
having something available at the front
desk
um we've mailed some smaller documents
to individuals
we're not smaller documents to the
fiscal committee we've mailed those
um the last couple of months it just
requires somebody to go into the office
and and make copies of all that and then
and drop it in the mail
because some of these are are documents
that we um
we don't have control of until just
prior to a meeting
um it does it does take a little time to
get some things to
organize and ready to mail or send out
or become available
once we have a solution i apologize
deliver all of them my door um
so once we have a solution and we have
some direction we will certainly get the
documents
and it may be something where we
intentionally wait
so that we know that there's a couple of
pieces of information that we want to
provide you but it's not available yet
for instance the treasurer will probably
talk about their offering statement
document when she comes on that's a
document that you should
i would recommend having that in a hard
copy if you can never get in a hard copy
it's a um
this is this isn't the latest one that i
have but this is one from
earlier and i just show you because i've
tabbed different things and it's easy
for me to go in
when there's a question made of me um
again that's not the most recent one
that's an older one but there's great
information in that document so
it may be something where we know
there's going to be pieces of
information that are going to come to
the committee
and we try to put a packet together so
that we can
kind of do it i've already talked to the
treasurer about that
and the challenge that we were coming up
with is the same one
we've been talking about is how do you
get it
out to every member in in a timely
fashion but i agree that
we all should have a copy of that
because it talks about
every facet of this state
from the retirement to schools to
education level everything that goes
into
what the bond council and the
bondholders want to know about
the fiscal responsibility and capability
i agree represent graham and um you know
there's a few documents like that um
that we typically would bring to you
when we
in in the old days so to speak
we come in with a pile of documents and
leave them for you and
and and talk to them um you know we
would work with the treasurer to make
sure we had the offering statements all
available to you so that you would have
that information and so it's just a
different time
trying to um accommodate the needs
coordination and direction and once we
have that we'll we'll get you
what we can but keep asking
don't don't be afraid to keep asking um
because the push you know the squeaky
wheel kind of makes some things happen
so okay
any further questions just on the
capital budget process
seeing them thank you very much mr shea
we it's appreciated
i'm sure we will be asking you for more
information along the way
not a problem and and in the document
you my email's there just go to our
website
shoot an email and and i will respond to
you um
so if you have any it doesn't even have
to relate to the capital budget if it's
a financial matter or a budget matter or
you just have a general question
feel free to reach out to our office
we may not have the direct answer but we
may be able to provide you
a contact of someone who does have that
answer
so so we do try to provide that that
assistance
okay brad do we know if the treasurer is
on yet
she is i just need to promote her one
moment okay
madam treasurer welcome we appreciate
you taking the time to
talk to us a little bit about um bonding
debt service servicing
debt service ratios and the rest i'm
sure we'll be asking a lot more
questions in the future
as we get the capital budget but this is
a good time to start
just so one you get to know us and we
thank you very much thank you for the
opportunity to be here it is my pleasure
um and yes so um
i'm sure there will be plenty of
opportunities for us to um to go over
this
and and to talk in the future once um
the capital budget isn't
um you know as a full uh force and
trying to implement one for for the
biennium um
so first what i would like to um just
mention is um
the chief deputy treasurer regime miller
is also on
and um i just asked her to stay
um by just in case um there are
questions that the committee may have
and um you know that way uh if there's
something i can
you know as i go through the
presentation um
you know she might be able to rescue me
um rachel has
um vast experience in capital budget and
bonding um so that's why i asked her to
join me today so um if
um i know she's she has logged in and if
brad is able to bring it on that would
be wonderful
brad can you bring her up
i guess i just promoted there she is
okay you're done
very good um so i see she is
she's coming okay so what i would like
to do today
is um mr chairman asked me
to you know provide you with an overview
of
essentially how we determine um what we
recommend what treasurer recommends for
capital budget and some of the tools
that we use to
determine that affordability so i would
like to share my screen today i have a
presentation that i just put together
just so you can see a few
you know some of the comments that i
would um
that i would like to share with you so
if you can just
okay
um okay i'm not familiar with this view
are you able to see the slide right now
absolutely looks good great
yeah very good so
um you know again i mean my my objective
today is to try to answer those
three basic questions that were um
mr chairman asked me to to provide how
we determine the amount that we
recommend
and um you know the process that
we go through to determine uh debt
affordability
and how we calculate those um you know
that metrics that help us
evaluate uh data affordability for the
state
so um essentially there are two
two two methods that we use two tools uh
two way to verify
our data affordability and the first one
is
we prepared a debt affordability study
um this
this study is prepared by state treasury
and also by the state's financial
advisor
we collaborate together to you know
calculate
um key debt metrics that
will help us determine whether the
state's levels will remain
manageable over the course of several
years
um you know the key the key that metrics
are debt to personal income
uh total net debt per capita
net debt service to general fund
revenues and
the key the key metric that we that we
use
is the debt to revenue ratio
you know the rating the rating agencies
use that ratio to measure
whether uh issuers uh have excessive
debt
service and so how if they're able to
manage that debt service
so i'll go into more detail in a moment
so i just want to describe the second
method the second method is in statute
is a debt limit calculation prescribed
in rsa 6-c
colon 2 and this law prohibits the
legislature from authorizing any
additional
net tax supported debt or debt paid with
general funds
funds that will result in actual and
projected debt
service exceeding 10 percent of
unrestricted
general fund revenue typically the
results of this calculation are
higher is there's a higher cap that the
one that we recommend through the data
affordability study
but this is this is certainly something
that is
formalized in statute and it's a way to
this limit serves as a guide rail to
prevent excessive borrowing
so now i'm going to go into more detail
to try to explain
um you know those two tools that we use
um the first one is a data affordability
study and that's the one that we use the
most
um the data for this this um
chart is just um it's a snapshot or an
easy way to
to review uh the data affordability that
we publish
every year so the latest the the last
one we did was the fiscal year 19 we're
about
we're about to um we're in the process
to to work on the and the new one we
expect to issue that over the next few
weeks
and that way you'll have that by the
time the capital budget is
um is introduced so what you see on the
screen right now
is um is
essentially the results of the data
affordability study
and it provides um the metrics that i
was just describing the first one
at the top of the top of the chart is is
showing our
general fund debt meaning the debt that
is paid with general funds and that's
that's the key
that drives um the debt to revenue
ratios that we calculate
uh for this for this study
the second ratio is net debt to personal
income
the personal income is obtained from
um
from the bureau of economic analysis and
the data that was used there was
um the data from 2018 so that gives us
a debt to a personal income of 0.6
percent
and the other one is the net debt per
capita
also the census the census from 2019
gave us information to
to to calculate
that debt metric and the last one as i
mentioned is
is the one that we paid the most
attention is
the debt to revenue ratio um
for fiscal year 19 it was 6.4 percent
this one is a projected one it's a
preliminary um
ratio of 6.8
uh and the rest are projections that we
do
essentially every year to see how these
levels are going to be managed
so that's what the data affordability
study does and what we
this is important because
the rating agencies is that is a
that is the metric that the rating
agencies use in order
again in order to measure how bond
insurers
um and and states or municipal issues
and managing their debt levels that is
as city new hampshire is characterized
for um having um a structure
and and good practices and maintain
um low levels of debt
so that is important to remember in this
study um
we recommended one authorization of 120
million
that has been uh recommended for several
biennia
and and and it's in in and it's a
typical
calculation that we we use
in order to see how the how the ratio is
going to perform
over several years the um
the rating agencies consider 10
as a warning level um
they don't want bond issues to reach
that 10
so that's something that we know that
this 10 percent is something we don't
want to reach
and so then the challenge now is to make
sure that our ratios are low enough
and consistent enough so the rating
agencies can
um you know this again this is only one
one component of what they evaluate but
but this is has been a positive
component
of the um of the credit rating that new
hampshire has received
um i guess during um
several years so so so this is the ratio
that we monitor the most
again new hampshire is recognized for
having
a higher wealth level so that's what
keeps the other ratios low enough and
one way we can compare this is a moody's
median
we're using here in this in this chart
um
the mood is median for 2020
for net debt to personal income was two
percent
uh net debt per capita was one thousand
seventy one dollars
and um and again the debt to revenue
ratio for them it was
uh three point one percent that's the
moody's uses a different way to
calculate this median and
and the debt-to-roman ratio but again
it's something that
is is is recognized as a good standard
to keep
um so so
not going into more details there i want
to move to the next
um to the next tool that is
established in statute and that is
the debt limit again prescribe and rsa
6.c colon 2. and what this
what this law says is that
essentially the legislature
can't authorize anything that is
any additional uh debt
that is paid with general funds that
will result
in actual and projected debt service
exceeding 10
of unrestricted general fund revenues
for the previous
fiscal year so what this chart does and
this is this is the certification so the
law
also says that the treasurer needs to
certify um
this amount to the legislative budget
assistance so we prepare this
certification
every year and this is the last one we
have
um so what this what this calculation
does is is as you can see in the in the
columns
we're including um the actual
and the latest again was uh was last
year's
um we're including the actual uh
debt service and we're also including
the second column we are include i guess
a stir cone
we include in um bonds authorized in an
issued
and and how we're going to amortize them
over time
and then we're also including uh
debt um there is guaranteed by the state
and that is
um that is that for example from
the business fire finance authority we
we have to include
um bonds that the state has guaranteed
um in case there there's a default there
and so then we come to a total and then
we compare it to
10 of fiscal year 2019
general fund and restricted revenues and
then the result is
um the last column is essentially
how much more um the stick
authorized according to this statute now
the the what this with this chart really
the result of this calculation
and you can see um in row
what we do is we run projections to
arrive to a bond authorization
that will result um the result of what
it is for that
debt service so when we ran those
calculations
um the result was that we
that there is a maximum of 600 million
that could be authorized
um used in this calculation
now um so again this is this is
um essentially a higher cap that we that
what the
um that affordability study provides
and so one thing i one thing that i did
is
um and i mentioned that in the bottom of
of this chart is if we were to um
if we were to enter that 600 million
into our
calculation our tool that we use for
that affordability study
um the debt to rental ratio could
increase or
would increase to approximately um 8.5
to
something between 8.5 percent to 9.5
percent
so clearly that will put us too close to
the
10 maximum that the rating agencies
don't want to see
so but this is again this is something
that is a stellar statute i think this
will provide
um it does provide a guardrail for
excessive
excessive borrowing perhaps that's not
something we want to
um get to but put it again if it's in
statue at least the legislature
um can approve more
um um you know
based on but you know couldn't approve
more
uh you know based on this um
we couldn't do more than that what this
is calculating
um but again we will probably um
what we what we use is the data
affordability study method methodology
um
you know to talk to you and to recommend
um the bond authorizations for a capital
so um i was trying not to get into too
much detail so hopefully i'm not
losing you yet um and again i just wanna
you know
based on what i what i was um describing
um you know these are the the the bond
considerations that this committee will
have to um you know decide as as the
couple
budget as being uh reviewed and proposed
um so the debt to rubbing a ratio of 10
percent again is the warning level
that the iranian agencies um monitor
and um that is a that is that is the
ratio that we monitor and we work
uh to make sure that um anything that
the treasury will recommend
it is it is consistent with what uh
treasury hazan um
historically and what will make you know
what will ensure
it will maintain um the rating the
career rating that uh new hampshire has
um this this
this slide also shows how um this ratio
has performed under the last few years
i guess going into beginning in 2000
um 2018 2019
um the ratio was declining and this that
was due
to the revenue performance uh that we
were having at that time
clearly that changed into end 2020
and it will depend on how how soon we
control the pandemic to to go back to
prepandemo
epidemic levels prior to 2017
there was this reclassification of the
medicaid enhancement tax revenues
from restricted revenue from
unrestricted revenue to restricted
revenue
and that's what drove the ratio um
higher and um the 2020 is
is a preliminary ratio again i was i was
just mentioning that
we're in the process to to confirm if
that's going to be the ratio based on
the revenues the other revenues that we
have
for fiscal year 20 and now we have to um
the job is going to be to to try to
determine some assumptions
of how the revenue is going to perform
um in the next few years
so we just we just typically um
prepare that and that's what um that's
what we feed into the methodology
and and that's what we'll calculate um
the new ratio and and to be able to
again another point i want to make is um
it's
some of the consideration so we work
really closely with the rating agencies
um
when we issue bonds we work really
closely with them to make sure we
provide them with information they need
to
to to to better assess the state the
financial health of the state and so we
can
um you know our goal will be doing to um
you know improve our creating writing um
uh but again right now we do have um
good ratings and that's what allows us
to to
um to maintain
lower costs for our general obligation
bonds
and so again um the the query rating is
what
influences the um you know the borrowing
costs uh
you know the better our ratings are um
obviously the cost will will decrease
our yields will be um
you know our bonds will be more
competitive and and
we could have 10 um lower yields uh for
our borrowing
um rating agencies um
focus you know they they have they focus
on a variety of components
the rainy um the balance and the rainy
day fund they focus on
the structural budget um and the
flexibility that states have
to control expenditures um they've been
the state's obligations such as medicaid
increases in medicaid spending pension
and post-employment liabilities um
all of that because they're concerned
that that could create um
additional fiscal pressures uh for the
state
so one way to to you know so so there
are so many
uh components that are not you know
they're difficult to control but there's
the debt the debt levels is something
the state can control
and that is and that is why um you know
it's important to maintain that
discipline
if we want to continue having that um
having that good positive or you know
essentially
those good points uh with the rating
agencies
and again the uh you know this this
formula and the debt-to-revenue ratio
revenues are difficult to to project to
estimate
um especially with you know the current
situation that we're living right now
um but the debt levels are something
that we can control we can manage
and and that perhaps you know
will help us continue with with the
financial health that new hampshire is
known for and
um and the last point um i want to make
is
um it is important to to to maintain
also borrowing capacity and this
is this is in the event of having
unanticipated capital needs
um you know for example the conquer
steam project
that happened a few years ago the fifa's
remediation project
additional 50 million was authorized
last year
so the recommendations that we will
provide to you
will probably look about the same and
and
and the committee will have to decide
and obviously the legislature will have
to decide
you know the the other matters are
important um
that um you know perhaps have
knowing that there is um additional bull
run capacity
you know perhaps that will um
help you determine one of the projects
and that is what i have today um
hopefully i didn't lose you as i was
going
um the last page of my presentation
is um you know some of the resources
that that
we have i was also um
um mr chair was
was mentioning that um we have the
official statements we do have plenty of
physical books that we could share with
you but in the meantime
we have these books posted online
that is the the link that will take you
there on our website
and so we have the official statements
and supplemental disclosures
we have the debt affordability studies
for the last several years and as well
as the debt limit certification that we
submit to the lba and we also have a
treasury dashboard my predecessor
created a treasure dashboard and that
dashboard
um includes um several
metrics that we track in the treasury
you know in the event that you want to
look at something
quickly and so that completes my
presentation
i'm going to try to um stop sharing my
screen
so i can ask any questions the community
thank you very much mountain treasure
it's informative
if you have questions please raise your
hand but i would ask that you
not ask the treasurer what the dollar
amount is going to be for the coming
capital budget
she's still refining that she's still
working with the governor's office on
that
um we will hear about that in a month
from now or so would we get
the capital budget and where she is and
what she's refined
but um just know that i wanted everybody
to know how she developed
the debt affordability study where it
came from
but right now she is in a process
with the executive branch to to come up
with
with a recommendation to us and
that will all be included when the
governor gives us
his capital budget and what he thinks we
should do
and how much we could spend because
whatever she gives us now
is going to change at all probability
unmute yeah yes i just wondered that
you know i found it very helpful to have
that dashboard
and i just wondered if you know that
could be provided to us
absolutely and there uh right now that's
being posted on a monthly basis
so um if you if you were like i could
even i could study melanity to you
the committee you know i will i will um
take any suggestions how you want to res
if you want to receive an email from me
i could do that i can't speak for the
rest of the committee but like i said i
found it most helpful
um what madam treasurer why don't you
just send the link to it
to the entire community and that way
they can if they want to save it they
can
because it does get updated and they can
check on it periodically rather than you
having to try to remember to send it out
every month or so
thank you and again it's posted on the
website um and i
i'll be happy to share this presentation
as well so you can um you know that
would be
but as a reference if if you would like
um to look at it in the future
that that would be helpful and and i'm
very sorry i didn't ask
um uh chief deputy treasurer she if you
wanted to add
anything in addition to what i what i
said
um
miss miller hey you're amir sorry
good morning okay i unmuted no i i
uh that was i i have nothing meaningful
to add that was
that was good so thank you thank you
representative faulkner yes thank you
um last last session we uh we learned
that there was some dispute with the
rating agencies over
how they were uh how they were treating
new hampshire
is there still that disagreement or if
we resolve those issues
um yeah i believe um
one of the rating agencies um
i'm not sure if we'll call it a dispute
but
perhaps my understanding is
uh um one of the reading agencies
uh in their description and and and
characterization of how the states
um this day was performing um
perhaps they were using um old
information so
um we had a meeting with with them in
the beginning of the year
and um we were able to explain to them
you know
the way we were seeing their evaluations
and um
that with that what that did is um they
revised
the way they were um assessing the state
uh at the time when um so so it was
helpful i think it was a
productive feedback that they receive
from from us from treasury
uh from our predecessor especially and
um
when the estate issue bonds in march
of last year um this
this rating agency smp upgraded the
state
um the outlook um the outlook of the
state change from stable to positive
so i think it was very helpful to to to
explain to them
that perhaps they were seeing the way
they were characterizing the state
was not um as accurate as
as it should have been um unfortunately
unfortunately the beginning of this you
know in the beginning of the pandemic
what that did is it allowed us to go
back to stable
uh when the pandemic started s p changed
the look of
the entire public sector including the
state and it had nothing to do with
the performance of the state it really
had to do with
uh how they were seeing um
the economy at that time and the
difficulties that the pandemic was
presenting
and how they were able to see that the
states were going to have
a challenge meeting revenue performance
and and all the variety of of challenges
that were
evident to them at that time um we we
sold bonds
um just this past december
um we did not get an upgrade but the
good news is that we kept our ratings
and and so again um
there in my opinion the way they see the
state is is very positive
um there were many states that were well
perhaps not many but there were states
that um
had grading challenges and some of them
were downgraded
um so it was very positive to see that
the city of new hampshire maintain those
ratings and and we were able to have
um in addition to that we we are bond
sold very competitively
um and and we obtained uh a very low
yield
uh of course the market was performing
um
it is the way the market is performing
the reason why we also had
um you know obtained low yield but but
again it's
it's important to to uh to recognize
that the state is doing a
terrific job with the finances
thank you any further questions
representative evil thank you mr
chair um thank you very much for the
presentation
so i i don't have the chart in front of
me now
but um we all believe and you've said
that new hampshire does really well in
its debt service ratio
and um the thing is what i saw there was
that the moody's
average net dirt debt service ratio was
3.8 percent
versus ours being 6.4 6.5
i saw the ratio to personal income for
new hampshire was much better
and also per capita but if it's not too
complicated i just
i mean there's a big difference between
3.8 and
point whatever yes and
um that that is a great question and and
moody's uses a different um way to
calculate
um their ratio and
um i believe i was looking at the report
yesterday and i believe
what what so the our ratio for moody's
is
also 3.8 percent what moody's does is
uh the reason the ratio is lower
is because moody's uh includes um
the education trust fund revenue as part
of
um as part of the overall formula
so um the other rate the the
the typical ratio we we calculate we
only use
unrestricted revenue but there there
they
include um again the education fund
revenue because they believe
um you know it's also considered
unrestricted revenue
even though it's used for education
funding but but that is the reason why
um moody's calculates the ratio in a
different way
for all the states and it is
3.8 percent um from the last report it's
3.8 percent
for new hampshire but again the um the
overall understanding and
how the other rating agencies see um
i guess a typical way to calculate their
ratio is
i hope that helps yeah thank you very
much you're welcome
anyone else only once thank you very
much madam treasurer
uh was informative and it was helpful
and i do appreciate
you making the time with you and and ms
miller to
to come over and talk with us today
my pleasure mr chairman um and now can
we reach any time
um i think i include again i'll i'll
share the presentation on
information as is is there but yeah
thank you very much
thank you
all right for those of you who hung in
till the end
um i appreciate you uh being here today
i i know it's not quite the same
trying to do it with this platform
because you don't get the interaction
that we normally would with both
the treasurer and each other but i
wanted to get us
started on the right foot at least
thinking about the
capital budget that affordability and
just a little bit about getting to know
each other um
they're not being anything i just gotta
i have an email from the speaker's
office that there's a chairs and vice
chairs meeting
in the morning to talk about how we're
going to go forward
so i will try to get as much information
out to you as i can
over the weekend but as i said earlier
do not plan on anything until the week
of the
january 25th um
so with that i appreciate everything and
i appreciate everybody who has stepped
up
um now we'll talk about that later but
um
i do appreciate it and i do appreciate
the fact that
all of you hung in here um for almost
four hours
um it is going to be long days if we
only get one day a week
in the the lob um so
let's work on it again thank you anybody
else have any final
if not brad thank you very much for
playing host
and setting this up i do appreciate it i
think all the members
do as well not a problem